Kekona
und und und
von those days that are gone.
Twitchy Moans,
from long ago,
made you feel,
you're not alone.
Kappa Pog Champ,
keep a forehead,
Bible Thumb,
Twitchy Moans.
I remember,
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Twitchy-Mod.
Oh, ich muss noch mal eine Pillen nehmen.
Vergessen.
Kappa PogChamp
So
Irgendwas stimmt mit meinem Headset noch nicht. Ist auch etwas weird champ, dass das jedes Mal unter Windows andere Sound Settings hat.
YouTube hat wieder keinen Bock.
YouTube, hallo?
Youtube, please.
Will nicht.
Aber das Hinterland geht noch, oder?
Leute, ja.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Okay, die Logik
muss man echt nicht verstehen.
So.
Jetzt aber. Moin, Leute.
Exzellent.
War gestern nicht on?
Weißt du, warum ich gestern nicht on war?
Gestern
Mittag
habe ich Pizza gegessen.
Selbstgemachte Pizza.
Ne, das stimmt nicht. Nicht gestern.
Blödsinn.
Vergesst, was ich gesagt habe.
Schwachsinn.
Vorgestern.
Vorgestern habe ich mir noch Pizza gegessen.
Da habe ich auch gestreamt.
Und abends, Leute,
hat mir übelster Bauchweh getan.
Warum auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Und um,
weiß ich nicht,
21 Uhr oder so,
musste ich ganz schön aufs Klo
und hab erstmal eine Runde gekotzt, zweimal.
Keine Ahnung, ob das an der Pizza lag
oder sonst was.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht,
dann
schone ich mich mal
gestern.
Und jetzt tut mir auch nichts mehr weh.
Aber ich werde heute auch
nicht gleich wieder Pizza futtern.
Ich hab gestern ein bisschen Suppe gegessen,
Das ging ganz gut und
ich esse heute ein bisschen Reis oder so, aber man muss es ja
nicht übertreiben.
Aber das war wirklich schon ewig.
Ich habe bestimmt 20 Jahre oder so, musste ich schon immer kotzen.
Also muss ja
irgendwas mit dem Essen gewesen sein.
Sonst kotzt man ja nicht einfach random.
Ne, wieder kein Lachs.
Meinst du der neue Youtube Player ist Vibe Coded?
Könnte ich mir direkt vorstellen
Weil eine Sache die mir aufgefallen ist
Ich bin ja
Wie heißt man das?
Player Leisten Enjoyer
Ich hab ja gerne diese Player Leisten hier unten eingeblendet
Und früher konnte man einfach
Über den Pause Button gehen
hier und dann ist das offen geblieben
und jetzt
geht das nicht mehr
und wenn ich hier drüber gehe
dann geht das auch nicht mehr
dann geht das noch, okay
aber im Fullscreen
glaube ich nicht, oder, ach, keine Ahnung
naja, zumindest, das ist auch
sehr weird, ja
ich finde es auch ehrlich gesagt blöd
warum gibt es nicht einen Button
so nach dem motto leiste immer offen lassen ich habe gelesen also sagt ständig fällt irgendwas
auf und hier github downtime da gibt es doch hier github status die haben ganz schön viele probleme
gehabt. Guckt euch das mal an.
Also keine Ahnung, was die da
getrieben haben.
Aber die
hatten richtig viele Probleme.
So, suchen wir mal nach Uptime.
Ich habe letztens gelesen, die kratzen
an den 90% Uptime.
Naja, oder auch nicht. Laut ihrer eigenen Seite haben sie 99,5. Guck mal, GitHub dropped below 90% to unofficial status page. Guck mal.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich kann euch jetzt nicht sagen, wie verlässlich die ist, ja.
Aber schon heftig.
Wenn du dir das anguckst, 9,824 Uptime.
Das ist jeder Raspberry Pi Service daheim.
Über alle Services.
Ja klar.
Also, die haben, guck mal, Copilot hat das meistens, also die haben das hier quasi so zusammengerechnet, ja, und dann kommst du halt, weil guck hier, guck hier ist grün, aber hier ist rot und so, also alle Services zusammen, aber ich finde das auch nicht, ich finde das aber auch gar nicht verkehrt.
Guck mal, Git Operations, Webhooks, API-Requests, Issues, Pull-Requests, Actions, Packages, Pages, Codespaces.
Okay, ich würde fernes halber Copilot rausmachen.
Wenn man Copilot rausmacht, sind wir wahrscheinlich bei 95% oder sowas.
Aber trotzdem, das ist trotzdem nicht gut.
Das ist trotzdem nicht gut.
Also Copilot scheint hier die meisten Probleme zu haben auf GitHub.
aber trotzdem also es ist schon also jeder jeder home lab tut mit dem
raspberry pi hat mehr abteilen als die github services zusammen jetzt natürlich
auch nicht toll
Ja.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen, die letzten
1-2 Jahre über.
Dinger, die ursprünglich
einfach immer mal funktioniert
haben. Wie gesagt, wie der YouTube-Player.
Wie der YouTube-Player oder
dieses Anzeigen von einer Statusbar im YouTube-Player.
Das funktioniert.
Ich habe teilweise Probleme, also die YouTube-App
auf dem Smartphone, da muss garantiert
irgendwas vibecoded sein, ja, manchmal
machst du die Comments auf, das Video
pausiert, warum auch immer, ähm,
dann versuchst du manchmal,
dann versuche ich manchmal das Handy zu kippen
und die YouTube App checkt es irgendwie
nicht, ja,
dann haben die also ein paar komische Premium
Funktionen drin, die auch
versuchen einem AI-Kram unterzuschieben,
es gibt jetzt eine Premium Funktion in der
YouTube App für iOS,
vielleicht auch für Android, wahrscheinlich auch für Android,
gehe ich mal stark von aus, die automatisch
Videos
schneller und langsamer machen kann,
je nachdem, wie ihre
AI erkannt hat, dass wichtige
Inhalte drin sind.
Auch ganz, ganz, ganz weird.
Was ich total oft
habe auf der YouTube-App, aber das ist seit Monaten
schon verbuggt, diese
Playlist, diese temporären
Playlists, die man sich anlegen
kann, also wo man dann sagen kann, hey,
ich will jetzt dieses Video gucken, danach
dieses Video, danach dieses Video, danach dieses Video, also ohne
eine richtige playlist anzulegen die verschwinden einfach öfters mal wenn man videos dann startet
also das ist das alles super verpackt und wisst ihr wisst ihr was eines der schlimmsten dinger
ist aber die war schon immer scheiße die raten selbst von copilot ab und empfehlen copilot
365 ich wusste gar nicht dass es ein unterschied ist also das alles die office war ja das alles
geht hat war ja noch hier war das schlimmste ist also eines der wirklich der mit abstand
könnt ihr mir mal schreiben im Chat, ob ihr das auch schon mal benutzt habt.
Eine ist der mit Abstand ekligsten App.
Das ist die Twitch-App für Android-TV.
Die ist so ruckelig, buggy.
Du klickst auf den Zurück-Knopf, du landest wieder auf der Startseite,
anstatt da, wo du gewesen bist.
Du kannst dementsprechend überhaupt nicht richtig Follow-Channels durchrollen.
Ohne Scheiß, die Twitch-App auf Android-TV, die ist so dermaßen schlecht,
was mir ein komplettes Rätsel ist, wie man so ein Ding
releasen kann. Die wäre wahrscheinlich
besser, wenn sie komplett gevibe-coded wäre.
Also sie ist wirklich richtig
mies. Wahrscheinlich ist sie
komplett gevibe-coded mittlerweile.
Wobei man sagen muss, sie war früher jetzt auch nicht wirklich so
viel besser.
Nutzt du die auch?
Ja, also das ist wirklich grausam.
Also das ist echt alles sehr, sehr
Pains. Pains Champ.
Aber die war, wie gesagt, die war noch nie gut
Oh, ich hab hier eine Kratzer auf dem Monitor
Sehe ich gerade
Könntest du jetzt ja wie Bibis
Beauty Palace machen
Chat, seht ihr den Kratzer auf meinem Monitor?
Komisch
Wenn ich einen Screenshot mache, sieht man den ja gar nicht
Ich hab so mal ein Video von der
So, warte mal, jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier
Die Kiste anmachen.
Zeit für einen neuen OLED.
Ich habe mir letztens zwar das Video angeguckt,
aber nächster Monitor wird wahrscheinlich
höchstwahrscheinlich ein OLED.
Aber ich sehe noch
keinen Grund, den auszutauschen.
Cashios.
Oder Cashios.
Hab ich vergessen zu starten?
Casios ist gestartet.
Oder auch nicht.
Elgato stellt's.
Doch.
Remote Control Session.
Achso, ja. Was auch immer man mir das sagen soll.
Ist egal, Hauptsache es funktioniert.
firefox, terminal, erstmal eine runde askiquarium, ach excellent, updates, ich sag ja wenn mein
system älter als 15 minuten ist, ist mir das nicht bleeding edge genug, muss alles geupdatet
werden, ich bräuchte eigentlich so einen background job der alle 15 minuten updatet
Und dann random das System nicht funktioniert.
Top.
Nothing to do.
Ups.
Chat.
Wie habe ich denn das hingekriegt?
Mein Westerm ist glaube ich gerade gecrashed.
Ich glaube wir haben auch Pac...
Haben wir zufälligerweise Pac-Man mitten im Upgrade kaputt gemacht?
Oder war das gerade fertig?
Pac-Man war bestimmt gerade fertig.
Und ich habe einfach STRG-D zu lang gedrückt.
Habt ihr zufällig gesehen, ob Pac-Man schon fertig war?
Das müssen wir jetzt gerade mal kurz kontrollieren.
Glücklicherweise streame ich ja.
Das wäre sehr nice.
Das ist auch so ein Ding auf Twitch, dass man als zweimal klicken muss.
Ganz schlimm.
So, ich würde gerne meinen eigenen Stream ohne Werbung gucken.
Das wäre sehr, sehr, sehr nice, Obi.
Okay, top.
Dann, Moment, warum kann ich nicht zurückscrollen?
Achso, Videos.
Hier, so, mal gucken, ob Pac-Man schon fertig war.
Lass mal checken.
Alter!
Das sind immer so kleine Dinger, die fucken mich übelst ab.
Warum kann das nicht einfach funktionieren?
Das ist bestimmt, weil das zum größten Teil Vibe-Code ist.
So, jetzt wollen wir mal zurück.
So, war das fertig jetzt?
Ne, oder?
Das war nicht fertig.
Das Pac-Man war nicht fertig.
Das lief mittendrin noch.
Wie war, Moment.
Init, RAM, FS, Generation, Arch, Linux.
Wie ging das nochmal hier?
Das, genau.
So, das machen wir jetzt mal von Hand, dass ich auch wieder booten kann.
Nur mal um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen
Wer weiß, ob das so eine gute Idee war
Pac-Man mittendrin abzubrechen
Also das war ja keine Absicht, das Terminal ist gecrashed
Hatte ich auch noch nie, dass West Ham gecrashed ist
Irgendwie zu schnell die Fenster geschlossen
Das hat es nicht mitgemacht
Okay
So, ich teste jetzt nicht, ob ich
Rebooten kann
Ich hoffe einfach mal, dass es funktioniert
Achso, Moment, wir müssen noch
Chaterino starten
Excellent
Fail to load channel badges
OAuth Token is missing
Jaja, gut
Aber
Die Badges sind doch da
Verstehe ich nicht
Guck mal
Totorans hat Badges
Was auch immer
Geben wir einfach mal nichts drauf
Dankeschön für den Sub
Exzellente
Subscription
Ja es ist Sonntag
Das stimmt
Ich bin aber auch ein bisschen verwirrt gewesen
Wegen dem Feiertag am Freitag
gestern abend hat youtube bei mir die volle christliche offensive gestartet
ich habe youtube aufgemacht und ich habe drei gottesdienst livestreams empfohlen bekommen
die wollten es echt wissen zweimal der papst zweimal der papst und dann auch irgendwas deutsches
Ja, zweimal Livestream vom Papst
mit deutschem Commentary
und dann auch
irgendwas deutsches.
Da war YouTube der Meinung, Max, du musst dir jetzt unbedingt
Gottesdienste angucken.
Warum auch immer.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz ehrlich,
eigentlich finde ich das jetzt auch gar nicht so wild,
dass das empfohlen wird.
Ich meine, kommt ja nicht so oft vor, dass das Feiertag ist in der Richtung.
Und für alle, die das interessiert, ist es doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Sollen sie machen.
Äh, ich finde das nicht schlimm.
Man muss es ja nicht anklingen.
Die zeigen ja das, wo die denken, dass dich das jetzt interessieren könnte.
Ist die Streamankündigung über Discord kaputt?
Ist sie das?
Vielleicht.
Aber das hatten wir ja schon ab und zu mal.
Das ist kaputt. Warte mal, ich mach's mal kurz auf und gucke.
Das hatten wir ja schon manchmal,
dass es ein bisschen rumbuckt.
Guck mal.
Seid mal hier.
Wo ist der denn?
Mein Channel.
Oh, fuck.
Discord laggt übelst rum.
Siebenkündigung vom 4.3.
Ja, die ist kaputt.
Die letzte hat noch funktioniert, die ist kaputt.
Aber das hatten wir schon öfters mal, dass die manchmal ein bisschen hängt.
Das buggt manchmal.
Ab und zu, so, was weiß ich.
Einmal im Monat oder so.
Warum? Keine Ahnung.
69 Zuschauer.
Exzellent.
Mir lieber als 67 Zuschauer.
Ich bin eh davon überzeugt,
dass bald 6.8 kommt, weil 6.7 hatten wir,
6.9 hatten wir.
Das ist eine logische Konsequenz, dass bald 6.8 kommt.
Wobei 6.7 ja schon
bei der Alpha-Generation
ist das ja schon wieder out.
Wenn das im Mainstream
und bei uns Boomer-Leuten angekommen ist,
dann sagt kein
Gen-Alpha-Typ mehr
6.7.
Das ist total out wieder.
Ups, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Was war das? Chat?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das gemacht habe
Wie habe ich das eben mit dem Fenster gemacht?
Das ist immer
Es gibt Dinger, die drückst du aus Versehen
Und weißt gar nicht, was passiert ist
So, dann würde ich sagen
gucken wir doch mal was auf github so trendet
oh ja das wird die nerven weil es schon wieder so outdated ist github trending
gucken wir mal
Gucken wir mal, was
Today trendet.
MLX
VLM
Okay, KI.
AI.
Open Screen.
Was ist das?
Das ist ja mal was, was irgendwie halbwegs interessant klingt.
Create stunning demos for free.
Open source, no subscription, no watermarks and free for commercial use.
Was genau ist das?
Open screen?
Alternative zu Screen Studio.
Ist das AI?
Was was was was was was was was was bin ich sehen was ist das
Professional screen recordings with zoom effects
annotations and beautiful backgrounds
Moment man kann damit das muss ich ausprobieren
Es gibt es auch für linux
Open screen
Okay, Download Linux.
App Image.
Das funktioniert bestimmt nicht richtig unter Wayland.
Könnte ich mir gleich vorstellen.
Gucken wir mal.
Gibt es das auch so zu installieren?
Open Screen.
Hast du das neueste Morpheus Video gesehen?
Nee.
Was?
Server im Weltall.
Warum wollen sie wirklich Rechenzentren im All?
Wollen sie das?
Na gut, dann starten wir mal das App-Image.
Schauen wir mal hier.
chmod plus x open screen.
Jett, wie viel wetten wir, dass das unter Wayland nicht richtig funktioniert?
Ne, wir wetten gar nicht, weil am Ende funktioniert das unter Wayland.
Aha, so jetzt haben wir hier so ein overlay Ding.
Screen.
Windows? Aha.
Äh, wo ist mein Westterm?
Hier.
Oh, Screen.
Screens geht schon mal nicht.
Es geht... Share?
Äh, ich will da nichts sharen.
Enable Webcam, ja, okay.
Webcam is blocked.
Sound, open video file,
open pro, was open?
Okay, so ganz check ich's noch nicht.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine elektron-based App.
Share.
Okay, und jetzt?
Record.
Haben wir doppelt einen Knopf hier oben?
Hallo, hallo.
Und wie zoome ich jetzt?
Aber ich will doch zoomen.
background blur so ganz check ich dachte man kann hier
zum z ach so das kann man erst post processing
Ach so.
Ich dachte, man kann on the fly zoomen und sowas.
Okay.
Ja, dann geht es auch unter Wayland.
Das war ja nicht...
Okay.
Aber ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist überleg...
Also wenn ich mal wirklich irgendwelche Screen Recording Sachen mache.
Mal wieder irgendwelche Security Sachen oder so zeige.
oder irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken oder sowas.
Ja.
Also sollte ich das mal auf YouTube wieder machen,
dann
ist es eigentlich gar nicht so übel.
Okay.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt seit langer Zeit
mal wirklich was gefunden in GitHub Trends,
was interesting ist.
T-Desktop.
Telegram Desktop Messaging.
Goose. Das habe ich ausprobiert.
Hat mich irgendwie nicht so richtig überzeugt.
Agent Framework.
Ja, was sonst Microsoft?
So, ne.
Okay, dann schalten wir das Ganze mal auf Weekly.
Guck mal, was rennt.
AI, AI, AI.
AI, AI.
Äh, wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich AI.
AI, AI.
Was Realtime Face Swap
and One-Click-Video Deepfake
with one single image. Oh, Chat.
Das wird bestimmt
nur für ganz ehrenwerte
Zwecke verwendet, dieses Programm.
Nicht das, woran man
jetzt vielleicht denkt.
Ich bin mir sicher, das werden die Leute
nur zu ganz ehrenwerten Zwecken
benutzen.
Save, ja.
AI.
1 sich oder vielleicht doch keine ahnung das ist ja wirklich die std wir hatten jetzt 99 prozent
ok language frau hat man mit kommt was trennt in sich schafft das ist immer das langweiligste
Spocks.
Das ist hier die
von dem
Garrys Mod Erfinder.
Die Game Engine
von dem Garry.
Das neue Garrys Mod.
Mit mehr Möglichkeiten ist das.
Genau.
Build on Source 2.
Und das coole ist, die haben einen Deal
gestrikt
mit
die haben einen Deal gemacht mit
Valve,
dass die Spiele,
die man in dieser Engine
baut, stand alone
auf Steam
veröffentlicht werden dürfen und nicht nur mit
S-Box.
Ich gehe mal davon aus,
das spricht beim Sandbox
aus, weil das halt ein Und ist.
AI.
Blockstrap.
Roblox. Alter.
Osu! Leute, dass
dass man wieder trennt osu das ist doch das ist doch was für unsere osu okay
sieht man jetzt nicht aber ich weiß dass das sehr beliebt ist bei den weeps
S-Translate
Avalonia trendet
zu Recht das einzig sinnvolle
Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework,
was es für .NET gibt und es kommt
nicht von Microsoft.
Hört mir bloß auf mit Maui,
das ist auch was, das
hat mich noch nicht so
überzeugt, ich hab das auch nur einmal kurz
angeguckt.
Rackpeak, haben wir uns
letztens schon angeguckt, fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Das ist quasi so ein Rack-Diagramm
ding moment das was anderes das was anderes das kenne ich gar nicht ich dachte das ist das letzte
mal angeguckt haben mit dem mit diesem grafischen rack was ist das denn das reggae im cli das
rechnen dass ihr in der command line naja ja für leute die so viel management von rechenzentrum
sachen machen so vielleicht gar nicht schlecht aber woher kriegt es denn seine daten wirklich
mal interessieren kann es das irgendwie das kauf an was eigentlich plötzlich kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen das muss manuell einfach fliegen oder ach hier server ja da sieht man es ja auch schon
server service das ist dann so was wo techno tim sein home lab mit malen kann würde neues video
um uns dann zu zeigen dass er jetzt fünf kubernetes notes hat anstatt 3 um um paywall zu hausen
stock sharp dls swapper
Was?
Ah, man kann DLSS upgraden, ohne dass das Game was neue Version rausbringen muss.
Aha.
Okay, das klingt eigentlich ganz sinnig.
Billy Billy Tool Pro.
War Billy Billy nicht dieses YouTube aus China?
Billy Billy
Oder auch nicht
Dann hab ich legit keinen blassen Schimmer
Was ist das? Gibt doch keine englische Readme
Oh, da stand doch irgendwas gerade
Billy Billy ist ein Automate Task Execution Tool
That acts as a helpful assistant
Aha
Billy Billy Tool
So, dann gucken wir mal, was trendet denn bei Rust?
Forge Code.
AI.
Äh, AI.
Chrome running inside your terminal.
Why?
Oh, drei...
Moment.
Das ist three years ago und trendet?
Hä?
Kann mir das mal irgendjemand
realistisch erklären?
Warum
trendet ein Projekt,
was drei Jahre alt ist?
Hä?
Community Fork?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht, warum das trendet.
Space Drive.
File Explorer.
Okay, das ist ein GUI File Manager.
Weiß ich jetzt schon, dass ich das garantiert nicht brauche.
Ein Ding, was ich immer doof finde, ist,
wenn die nicht einen Screenshot haben.
Warum haben die nicht gleich einen Screenshot?
Hier haben sie doch auch einen Screenshot.
Was?
jetzt check ich gar nicht was es ist local first data engine index everything naja das
ist also nicht nur ein file manager das ist bookmark oder sowas bookmark manager
unschlüssig genau was das ist
zellige trendet habe ich mal ausprobiert so als
thema alternative die eben noch mehr zeug kann hat mich jetzt nicht so richtig überzeugt ich
bleibe bei meinem terminal was so gut wie alles was thema gemacht hat abdeckt die box
halt einfach nur noch auf dem server alles andere brauche ich nicht screen
pipe und starship ok und dann schauen wir als letztes mal was trennt denn so
moment moment kobold was trennt denn bei kobold nix wir stars this week kobold
aws samples aws mainframe modernisation kart demo aber es ist eine aws ist eine
kobold anwendung für aws
JCL ist diese Host-Jobsprache, oder?
Unikix.
App.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal...
Kobold an.
Äh, Moment.
Was ist .mac?
Ich dachte, wir kriegen irgendwie...
Assembler?
What the fuck?
Ich dachte, wir kriegen hier
krasses Kobol.
Ist das, Chatge, ist das Kobol?
Wir machen kein Kobol-Stream mehr.
Einmal hat mir gereicht.
Also ich hab
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was ich hier überhaupt sehend bin, ja.
AWK?
Scripts?
Okay, whatever.
Abgedrehtes Zeug, Kobol-Stells, trendet.
Vier Sterne this week.
Das reicht für Kobol zu trenden.
Das heißt, unser nächstes Projekt sollte in Kobol sein, oder?
Damit wir einfach auf GitHub trenden.
Problem ist nur, dass es halt schwierig ist, irgendwas Anständiges in Kobol auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
abab für die sap enjoyer geht klein vor abab alter will man sich das wirklich antun abab geht
tatsächlich das heißt ist es jetzt ein geht klein dem man sap verwenden kann oder was
Eclipse Plugin
Okay, guck mal was letztes
Was in Go so trennt
Da kommt vielleicht ein bisschen was
Sinnvolles bei rum
Wieder das Ding, wo ich das letzte Mal
Schon nicht genau wusste, was es ist
Aber wo ich nicht gecheckt habe nach dem Lesen
was es genau ist.
Ähm, nee, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes.
Aber egal, das
ist AI.
AI.
Also ist das
Lightweight Server Monitoring.
Aha.
Sowas wie, sowas wie Dings hier.
Äh, Uptime Kuma oder sowas, hä?
Warum brauche ich
Okay.
Ich find's ja nice, dass das alles gibt, ne?
Aber ich stoß bei solchen
Lightweight-Monitoring-Sachen
immer richtig schnell an meine Grenzen.
So.
Es ist halt die Frage, kann man da zum Beispiel
Custom-Checks machen?
So was wie, ähm...
Mal genommen, ich will jetzt einen Check machen,
wie schnell meine Internet-Connection ist,
weil es da, will ich einfach überwachen, einmal
nachts, einmal nachts irgendwie ein paar
Curls
machen und gucken, wie schnell das ist und so
und das kriegt man dann hier wahrscheinlich nicht rein,
weil es nur die vorgefertigten Dinger
Außerdem ist halt die Frage,
wie viel das mit gut,
also wie gut das klarkommt mit vielen Checks,
wobei das sich ja, denke ich mal,
an Home-Usage
richtet, da gibt es ja nicht so
viel.
Ja.
Ist aber cool, dass es das gibt.
Ich bin immer wieder froh, wenn es neue Monitoring-Projekte gibt.
Mein Traum ist es ja, irgendwann mal mit ein paar Leuten zusammen, die so ähnlich ein Background haben,
ein Monitoring-System zu bauen.
So best of aus 20 Jahre Admin-Erfahrung.
und so wie ich mir es vorstelle,
dass ein gescheites Monitoring-System
aufgebaut sein sollte.
Das werde ich nie machen,
weil alleine ist das zu großer Akt.
Kostet insgesamt eh zu viel Zeit
und außerdem gibt es ja schon
mehr oder weniger für alles was.
Aber ich finde,
es gibt halt keine
schöne Monitoring-Lösung.
Es ist alles irgendwie Crap.
Prometheus mit Grafana zusammen
ist gut für Metriken.
Ja, aber für so klassisches Is-Up, Is-Down Monitoring ist das nicht so geil.
Ich weiß, dass das geht, ja, aber bei Prometheus ist halt prinzipiell erstmal alles eine Zahl, also alles eine Metrik.
So Sachen wie letzter eingeloggter User geht nur um Umwege, ja, dass man dann sagt, last login time und dann mit Label und sowas in der Richtung.
Also man kann das meiste damit abbilden.
bilden aber für so klassisches ort offen port down server ab pink pink nicht irgendein custom
check wie schnell ist meine internetverbindung und sowas da ist man tatsächlich teilweise mit
der klassischen monitoring lösung und vielleicht in den best script check besser bei es gibt für
prometheus sehr viel es gibt auch schon viele fertige exporter ab prometheus ist wenn es über
Metriken sammeln hinausgeht,
ja, also über das, wofür es
gemacht ist, ist das
ein ziemliches, bau dir deine eigene
Monitoring-Lösung.
Hier hast du die einzelnen Teile. Du kriegst
einen Alert-Manager, du kriegst Prometheus, du kriegst
Grafana, du kriegst
vielleicht noch irgendeinen,
wie heißt dieses
Dashboard?
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Das, was ich finde,
was so
weird champ aussieht.
Nicht Dashboard.
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt.
Es gibt so ein Dashboard,
das sieht super weird aus, ist aber relativ beliebt.
Da gibt es auch
Kubernetes-Zeug drin.
aber vergessen wie das heißt irgendwas mit dem ball ich den namen sehe weiß ich
weil er lern manager selbst bringt janett
okay ich habe vergessen wie das heißt ja das ist mehr so bild in ein eigenes
monitoring und so klassische sachen wie zabbix oder meinetwegen auch nagios
wobei ich nagios seit zehn jahren oder so nicht mehr benutzt habe aber nagios
hat so platz in meinem herz ja ich mag nagios zabbix ist halt das ding zabbix
kann auch irgendwie alles bei größeren installationen ist es halt etwas weniger
effizient wenn du damit auch viele viele werte sammelt weil hat jeder einzelne
punkte eintrag in der datenbank ist in der klassischen sql datenbank dafür kann
es habe ich es nahezu alles probleme hat es ist auch ein bisschen dass das die
bedienung ist halt echt für ein arsch ja das web interface ist checkt keiner
also so eine
irgendwie fehlt mir noch was irgendwie fehlt mir eine monitor ja für so so so
liebere nms und sowas das ist cool wenn man sachen hat die psnp gehen irgendwie
fehlt mir noch was was so meinem gefühlten besten workflow entspricht so
das stimmt wir müssen kobold stream machen alles da anders da komme ich in
trends perfekt ja wie findest du was ich habe nie verwendet aber ich kann dir
sagen was ich an ptg und perfekt finde dass es nicht auf linux läuft das ist
glaube ich so ziemlich das unperfekte was man sein kann für eine monitor
lösung die ich betreiben will es ist wenn das only also der server
der server ptg server ist wird das macht es enorm und perfekt aus meiner sicht
Ansonsten kann ich zu PRTG nichts sagen, weil ich es nie verwendet habe.
Aber alles was nicht unter Linux läuft ist halt für mich von Arsch.
Genau, das wäre es jetzt noch.
PRTG mit Wine
auf Linux laufen lassen.
Das Schlimme ist, wahrscheinlich wird es sogar noch
funktionieren.
Moment.
Das muss ich jetzt nachgucken.
Ob das funktioniert.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ah ja, ja.
Ist nicht unterstützt oder verantwortlich.
Ach.
Ach, warum?
Also das ist glaube ich keine allzu geile Idee.
Außerdem kommen dann noch die Lizenzkosten und alles dabei.
Die muss man ja trotzdem bezahlen.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ja schon mal ein richtig großer Minuspunkt.
Chat, jetzt mal eine Frage an euch.
Geht jetzt einfach mal von aus.
Ich sage nicht, dass es das ist.
Ich glaube, wenn ich PRTG benutzen würde, würde ich auch viele Sachen finden, die mir auf den Sack gehen würden.
Aber gehen wir mal theoretisch davon aus.
PRTG wäre die perfekte Monitoring-Lösung, die alles so macht, wie ihr gerne wollt.
Gehen wir mal von aus, ich sage, es ist mit Sicherheit nicht so, ja, aber gehen wir mal theoretisch von aus, es wäre so.
Würdet ihr dann dafür einen Windows-Server betreiben wollen? Nur dafür?
Also, restliche Sachen bei euch ist nur Linux, reine Linux-Infrastruktur, aber ihr hättet die perfekte Monitoring-Lösung.
Einziger Drawback wäre, ihr müsstet dafür Windows betreiben.
Nee, never
Ich auch nicht
Würde ich auch nicht machen
Wobei ich es mir vielleicht mal kurz angucken würde
Und überlegen, ob es das wert wäre
Einfach so pauschal, nee
Würde ich nicht sagen
Aber ich glaube, nachdem ich mir es angeguckt hätte
Würde ich zu nee tendieren
Bei Virtualisierung, da hast du ja immer noch ein Windows laufen
Ob das jetzt ein virtualisiertes Windows ist
Oder ein echtes Windows, ist doch egal
Also ein Bare Metal Windows
Also allein schon, dass du ein Windows betreiben musst, würde mich abfangen
Und ich würde es wahrscheinlich
Höchstwahrscheinlich eh, also ich betreibe ja die meisten Sachen
Dann virtualisiert für sowas
Ja, aber würde ich nicht machen
Also allein schon, dass ich mich um Windows kümmern muss
Soll ich euch mal was witziges erzählen
Was bezüglich Windows
Ich betreue einen Service bei uns
auf der Arbeit. Das ist so ein Sammelbecken.
Das ist eigentlich mal ursprünglich entstanden,
also bei uns
auf der Arbeit ist das so,
wir betreiben Server, die gehören in der Regel, sind die
einem Service zugeordnet. Und dieser Service
hat dann auch definierte Ansprechpartner.
Ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, weil da kannst du nie das
Problem haben, hier steht eine Kiste,
ich weiß nicht, wer dafür zuständig ist. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Das muss man denen echt mal lassen.
Organisatorisch sind die viel, viel,
viel, viel besser
als mein alter Arbeitgeber.
So, aber das ist so, ich habe so einen Service, ich habe dann irgendwann auch gesagt, so ey, komm, wisst ihr, mach ich, ja, ist egal, ist ja nicht viel.
So, das ist so ein Sammelbecken, der ist mal ursprünglich entstanden, weil bei uns, also wir machen ja hauptsächlich Linux bei uns im Team und jeder hat eine Linux-Admin-VM, wo er gut drauf ist und machen kann, was er will.
So, und die mussten halt irgendeinem Service zugeordnet werden.
Daraufhin wurde damals ein Teamservice angelegt, der halt so heißt wie unser Team.
Und da waren diese VMs drin.
Mittlerweile ist dieser Service ein Sammelbecken für alles mögliche.
Für irgendwelche, ich teste meine Ansible-Rollen-Testserver, Admin-Kisten,
Grafana stehen da zwei rum.
Es steht eine Prometheus-Kiste, eine Viktoria-Metrix-Kiste rum.
Also komplett wildes Sammelsorium.
Da steht zwar offiziell mein Name dran für diesen Service,
aber ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer von den meisten der Kisten da drin.
Ich kann die Grafana-Kisten update ich regelmäßig.
Zumindest habe ich letztens festgestellt,
da steht ein Windows-Server, der diesem Service zugeordnet ist.
Was heißt, ich müsste eigentlich gucken,
dass der regelmäßig geupdatet wird und sowas.
Da habe ich auch erst mal keck-weighted, Alter.
So habe ich es dann gemacht.
Aber glücklicherweise haben wir im Team einen Windows-Fan, der macht das immer.
Das heißt, ich habe mich da, obwohl ich für den Service zuständig bin,
noch nie eingeloggt und weiß überhaupt nicht genau, was das macht.
Ich glaube, das Ding hat, glaube ich, irgendwelche SQL,
Microsoft SQL Frontend-Admin-Dinger drauf oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Will ich auch gar nicht wissen.
Ich halte da wirklich Abstand von.
Ich wurde als Linux-Engineer eingestellt.
Ich engineering nur Linux, ich engineering kein Windows.
Wenn die sagen würden, Max, du bist jetzt Linux und Windows Engineer in einem und kriegst dafür das doppelte Gehalt,
dann würde ich mir, ich bin ja käuflich, ne, dann würde ich mir das überlegen.
Aber das wird nicht passieren und außerdem will ich auch mit Windows nichts zu tun haben.
Was ist denn das? Ist das sowas wie Jammel, nur mit S am Anfang?
Was ist Sammel, Jammel?
Sammel?
Was zum Teufel ist Sammel?
Sammel ist
XML-Document.
Alter, hör mal bloß auf.
Sammel ist ein offener Standard
mit Internet-Ititäts-Provider-Autorisierung.
Okay, es ist
XML.
Wenn ich das schon höre, kriege ich Anf-
Ist das XML?
Es ist XML. Ohne es habe ich irgendwas mit SAP
gerade gelesen. Ne, glücklicherweise nicht.
Sammel L-Checks.
Okay, es ist von 2005.
Übrigens, ich-
Ich zitter nicht, Leute.
Das ist die Maus, dieser Maus-Remote-Maus-Sharing.
Das spackt manchmal ein bisschen rum und dann
zittert die Maus so.
damit will ich auch nichts zu tun haben
take viagra die hat dankeschön für den sap exzellente subscription
iq bus ja plus eins für alle im chat aber gilt erst ab dem zeitpunkt also man muss
bevor das abkommen drin gewesen seinem chat keine ahnung ich weiß nicht was es ist das
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich davon was gehört habe eben.
Okay.
Dann lass mal schnell durchgucken, was bei Go so trendet.
Also AI, Server Monitoring, Telegram-Proxy.
Ah, das ist cool.
Solar Charging.
Wenn ich mal Solar Panel habe, dann werde ich mir auch EVCC draufhauen.
Ich meine, eine Wallbox mit MQTT-Unterstützung habe ich ja schon.
Kann ich übrigens empfehlen.
Ich habe das Ding jetzt ja seit...
Seit wann habe ich mein Elektroauto?
Seit...
2022, glaube ich.
Irgendwie Anfang 2022.
Wilder Igel, danke schön.
Brock, danke für den Sub.
Also seit ungefähr vier Jahren habe ich jetzt mein Elektroauto.
Und ich habe mir ja damals so eine Go-Charger oder so wie dieses Ding hieß.
gekauft.
Ähm,
OI-Charger.
Ah, die sehen jetzt mittlerweile
ein bisschen anders aus.
Die sehen besser aus mittlerweile.
Den Charger, den ich mir gekauft habe,
der sah noch ein bisschen sehr
ein bisschen sehr bastelmäßig aus.
Das sind schon die neuen.
Okay, ähm, alt.
Ich habe noch so einen alten, so einen blauen mit blau.
Sieht man...
Gibt's gar nicht mehr.
Genau so ein Ding
hab ich noch hier. Die sah noch ein bisschen...
Hier so ein Teil. Die sah noch ein bisschen...
Experimenteller aus zu dem
Zeitpunkt.
Wo ich das Ding geholt hab.
Zumindest...
Was ist denn das?
Zumindest muss ich sagen,
ich bin sehr glücklich mit diesem Charger.
Der Grund...
äh, AF-Programmer, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ähm, der Grund, warum ich mir das Ding damals gekauft hab, ist,
weil ich geguckt hab, welche Sache kann, also welche Wallbox, welchen Charger,
kann man am besten in seine Heimautomatisierung integrieren
und welchen Charger kann man am besten quasi auch steuern
oder hat besten APIs und sowas in der Richtung.
Dann bin ich auf den gekommen, das ist nämlich richtig nice, der hat,
passt mal auf,
Weder einen i3 noch einen Tesla.
Achso, ich dachte, du meinst, welches Auto ich habe.
Ne, du meinst Wechselrichter oder was?
Auto. Auto habe ich einen Fiat.
Ich habe einen Fiat 500e.
So ein Ding hier.
Instruction.
Ja.
Das ist der Neue.
Hier, guck mal. Die Dinger haben nämlich
plus Cloud. Cloud wusste ich
gar nicht, dass es da ist. Die Dinger haben Modbus.
Das ist für die ganzen Hardcore-Leute.
OCPP.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Aber
die haben auch eine HTTP. Das ist das, was
mich interessiert hat. Die haben eine HTTP-AP
und MQTT.
Eigentlich mega nice, ne?
Inklusive Docs, wie man das Ganze anspricht
und sowas.
Das Ding kann sich ins WLAN reinhängen.
übrigens hier chat guck mal erkennt ihr das hier erkennt ihr dieses sport was könnten das sein
habt ihr eine idee also sieht so sieht das innen drin aus wenn ihr wenn ihr dieses ding hier
anguckt sieht verdächtig nach dem sp 32 aus es kann auch ein sp 2 nach 66 noch sein ich glaube
es ist ein ESP32.
Es könnte aber, wie gesagt, auch ein ESP286
sein. Was ich eigentlich ganz cool finde,
dass man das hier quasi
in freier Wildbahn in einem fertigen Produkt
so sieht. Vor allem, das ist halt auch noch
so ein Entwicklungsboard. Also, wie gesagt,
die Version damals war noch ein bisschen experimenteller,
hatte ich den Eindruck.
Das ist auch nur aufgesteckt, so wie
es aussieht, ja. Aber sehr cool
und das war der Grund, warum
ich mir das Ding damals bestellt habe.
Weil du halt HTTP-APIs hast,
MQTT-APIs und sowas.
Und ich habe das von Anfang an bei mir in Home Assistant eingebunden.
Ich kann jetzt halt ganz genau sehen, wie viel da durchgeht, ob er gerade chargt, in welchem Modus er ist, alles mögliche.
Ja, tausend Sachen kann man da abfragen.
Und das wäre halt richtig cool in Kombination, wenn ich wirklich mal ein Solarpanel hätte oder, keine Ahnung, Balkonkraftwerk oder so.
Wobei ich habe keinen Balkon, also schwierig in Balkonkraftwerk.
Zumindest dann würde ich mir EVCC holen.
Und da könnte ich auch hier noch gucken, Batteriestatus vom Auto und alles mögliche und wie viel geht rein und wie viel geht raus und sowas.
Dann hätte ich das am Start.
Jetzt rein ohne Solarpanel ist das jetzt nicht so dolle.
Was bezahlst du eigentlich für Strom? Weiß ich gar nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Was es jetzt gerade ist, keine Ahnung.
Ich gucke auch lieber nicht nach.
Ist wahrscheinlich besser.
Das stimmt, ich habe ein Haus, aber ich habe kein Solarpanel.
Dadurch, dass ich ein Haus habe, könnte ich immerhin jederzeit ein Solarpanel aufs Dach machen.
Wenn das nicht so teuer wäre und die Wartezeiten so lang wären.
Wobei ich glaube preislich
Ist es gar nicht
Gar nicht mehr so krass
Mittlerweile und die Auftragslage
Ist auch glaube ich gar nicht mehr so
Krass ausgelastet also ich glaube es geht
Aktuell
Aber ich habe trotzdem
Keinen Bock irgendwie 15k auszugeben
Einfach mal so
Also das kostet
Geh mal stark von aus
Habe ich jetzt einfach mal so aus dem Bauch raus gesagt
Aber ich denke mal so in dem Dreh wird es wahrscheinlich liegen
Dafür hätte ich halt auch die eine Seite vom Dach dann voll
Lieber ein fünftes Nass
Ja, richtig
Wir könnten uns mal, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Es gibt doch noch
Wie heißt dieser andere Hersteller
Irgendwas mit A
AOT
ne, äh, W
wie heißt denn dieser Hersteller
nicht Anker
nicht Asustore, ne, ne, ne, ne
so ein kurzer, so ein kurzer, kurzer
Name
der hat, der macht auch gute
Nass, Nass, Nass-Tests
Nass-Comparers
Guck mal mal.
Nassfinder.
Nicht Synology Nass.
QNAP.
Nee.
Irgendwas.
Was nicht so bekannt ist.
Ähm.
WD.
Nee.
WTF.
Alter.
Wir hatten diese Webseite gebaut.
Das ist ja grausam.
Alter.
WTF.
Nass.
WTR oder so.
WTR.
Das meine ich.
Genau.
Wow. Die Dinger sind jetzt
zumindest, wenn man Reddit liest,
auch recht angesagt. Das ist auch China-Chinesen.
China-Chinesen-Nass.
Ah, Aosta-Nass.
Guck mal mal, was die haben.
Oh Leute, ich merke gerade, ich war heute noch gar nicht auf dem Klo.
Es drückt.
Ram ist teuer
Na mit A
Aus da
Hast du was getrunken?
Ja, ich hab schon fast meinen Tee leer
Also Ram kannst du bei denen kaufen
Aber
Der kostet halt ordentlich was
Lass uns mal kurz gucken
Was die für Nasses haben
Ob da was interessantes dabei ist
Wenn da nämlich was interessantes dabei ist, preis-leistungsmäßig, dann kaufe ich mir einfach noch ein fünftes Last-Dom ausprobieren.
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Also das hier klingt doch erstmal recht interessant von dem, von der Size her.
Ukraine hat einen Kickstarter? Was? Was war das Ukraine-Kickstarter-Desaster? Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Also was ist das hier für eine CPU?
Ryzen.
Ein Mobilprozessor Ryzen.
Mit.
Mit was?
8 Kerne, 16 Threads.
Das Ding ist gar nicht mal übel.
Die CPU, die da drin ist, die hat ordentlich Wumms.
Gar nicht mal schlecht.
Also für 349 Euro?
Es hat sogar noch DDR4-RAM.
DDR4-RAM ist ja mittlerweile heute fast schon ein Verkaufsargument.
Weil es billiger ist.
Aber nicht so viel billiger.
Dann hast du zwei NVMe-Slots.
Auch top.
Firma SATA, auch okay.
Die Frage ist, kriegt man da irgendwie
10 Gig Netzwerk rein?
Traust der Hardware nicht?
Okay, warum?
Äh
Das ist glaube ich so ziemlich
Das dümmste erste Bild
Was man für eine NAS machen kann, oder?
Die Leute sitzen mit ihrem NAS
Am TV und gamen
Warum ist das das erste Bild?
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben
und es ist wahrscheinlich ein KI-Bild, ja, aber das ist
trotzdem richtig hängen geblieben, das ist absolut
nicht das, wofür das gedacht ist
oder vielleicht denken die sich
das aber nicht, wofür es das gemacht ist
Nass Gaming
Naja, komm, so schlimm ist das bei mir
jetzt auch nicht, das Ding, na gut
okay, sagen wir mal so
das Minisforum Nass ist schon nicht das geilste
in Bezug auf, warum haben die SSDs
manchmal Performance Drop und warum schwankt
die Netzwerkkarte so. Aber das ist immerhin
noch auf hohem Niveau.
Die Netzwerkkarte ist, zumindest mit dem
Herstellertreiber, immer noch
8,5 Gig plus
im Vergleich zu 9,5.
Okay, aber in Ordnung.
Und was mit den SSDs ab und zu ist,
keine Ahnung. Aber das ist immer noch auf hohem Niveau. Der Rest ist
ja top. Ich muss sagen, das
Ugreen hat mir von der Hardware echt ganz gut gefallen.
Wenn das Ukraine noch ein PC Express Slot hätte und...
Ups, was hab ich da gerade angeklickt?
Was?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab irgendwelche China-Chinesen-Zeug hier markiert.
Ja, also wenn das Ugreen hätte das Ugreen noch ein PC Express Slot und eine stärkere CPU, dann wäre das Beste.
Bei Ugreen außerhalb von Kickstarter eine Vorbestelleraktion, da haben wohl zu viele Leute mitgemacht.
Dann hat Ugreen nur ein paar hundert Geräte auf Kickstarter geworfen.
Die Seite war dauernd, fast alle gingen leer aus.
Okay.
war es mittlerweile ist es aber auf 7 ich habe das auch schon vor dem jahr oder
so gekauft als es dann nicht mehr stadia exklusiv war oder vor drei jahren oder
so oder vor fünf jahren stadia ist ja mittlerweile auch schon eine ganze weile
älter und chat weil ich schon wieder vergessen haben so sah das damals aus
der untergang des des lokalen gaming wurde damals heraufbeschworen von leuten
in den YouTube-Comments. Ich habe mir damals schon
gedacht, ah, ich weiß
nicht. Und
Negativ-Latency, ja.
Das 885,
das kommen wir uns gleich an.
So, lass mal kurz schauen.
Was hat denn das Ding so an Connectivity?
Interface-Information.
Dum-dum-dum.
Dum-dum. 2x
2,5 Gig.
Okay, ich hätte
schon gerne 10 Gig. Das ist
in der Tat etwas
Fail von denen, dass sie kein
10 Gig drauf gemacht haben.
Die hätten 10 Gig drauf machen sollen, weil ganz im Ernst,
die Hardware und sowas ist mehr
als cap... Nein.
Ist mehr als dazu in der Lage...
Ist mehr als capable.
Alter, manchmal ist mein Denglich echt nicht mehr...
Nicht mehr...
Auszuhalten, nicht mehr normal.
Also die Hardware ist mehr als in der Lage
10 Gig auszulasten.
Und gerade mit NVMe-SSDs.
Das wäre schon nice, ja.
Also das ist ein bisschen verschenkt und ich will einen 10GB NAS haben.
Ich meine, ich habe nicht umsonst seit Jahren 10GB Hardware und dann kaufe ich mir jetzt einen 2,5GB NAS.
Ne.
2,5 für Festplatten noch vollkommen ausreichend.
Wir reden aber nicht von Festplatten.
Wir reden oder auch von SATA-SSDs.
Für SATA-SSDs wäre es auch...
Ah.
Also 2,5GB hat...
Wie viel kriegt man bei 2,5 Gig?
Warte mal.
125 plus 125
plus
125 durch 2.
Ey, man könnte auch...
Chat, warum mach ich's eigentlich so kompliziert?
Warum sag ich nicht 125 mal 2,5?
High IQ Quick Maps, Alter!
Aber immerhin, ja.
Also, das reicht nicht für SATA-SSDs auszulasten.
Das reicht nicht um SATA-SSDs.
Aber gehen wir mal von aus.
Also wenn man, ja, wenn man da rein Festplatten...
Aber selbst mal Festplatten reicht's nicht.
Weil wenn du vier Platten reinmachst...
Vier Platten bietet sich ja ein RAID 10 zum Beispiel an, ja.
Also Stripe mit Mirror.
oder oder ist es mir um mit stripe ich kann mir das immer nicht werden was ist
in raid 10 den stripe mit dem mirror drüber oder zwei mirrors mit dem stripe
drüber ich glaube zwei stripes mit dem mirror
drüber oder kann ich mit normaler mensch kann sich diesen kram so lange
nach der prüfung merken er meine prüfung ist 20 jahre her
ja und dann reicht die auch mit magnet festplatten nicht mehr aus bei
sequenzieller Übertragung. Also 2,5 Gig
ist echt etwas
schwachbrüstig. Man könnte jetzt
sagen, okay, man könnte ja vielleicht irgendwie
Port Aggregation oder sowas machen mit
2x2,5. Dann brauchst du wieder
Hardware, die das unterstützt und hast vielleicht ein paar andere Probleme.
Also 10 Gig wäre schon nice.
Was
eventuell eine... Ach guck mal,
der hat sogar eine USB 3. Der hat
nichts Neueres. Weil ich wollte gerade sagen, man könnte
theoretisch auch noch
vielleicht eine USB-Netzwerkkarte dran machen.
Aber das reicht ja dann auch
nicht richtig.
Was ist ein USB 3?
Das schnellste.
Max Speed.
5 Gigabit.
Ja, und das wirst du wahrscheinlich
dann auch nicht richtig bekommen.
Ja, okay.
Daran sieht man jetzt halt auch,
das muss auch eine ältere Plattform sein,
weil es ist nur DDR4, es hat noch
keine neueren USB-Anschlüsse.
Sprich dafür, aber gut,
ich meine ganz ehrlich, der Preis
ist wirklich gut.
auch dafür.
Also wenn einem das ausreicht,
so 300 MB
die Sekunde für sein NAS und
man da jetzt nicht irgendwie noch
irgendwelche anderen Spirenzen mit PC Express Karten
machen, wenn sowas, ist das echt
in Ordnung. Ja, die CPU
ist sehr ordentlich.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde,
tatsächlich ist
Power Consumption, was das Ding
hat.
Moment.
Au, au, Star.
Muss versuchen.
Ist ja absolut nicht zahmend hier.
Power Consumption ist 20 Watt
mit nem...
mit 2 NVMe.
Ja, das ist jetzt, muss man
sagen, das ist jetzt nicht super
schlecht. Das ist jetzt aber auch weit
davon entfernt richtig gut zu sein.
also richtig gut
Idle Power Consumption ist bei mir
irgendwas um 8 Watt
ok ist irgendwas
zwischen
15 und 20
gut ist
irgendwas um 10 bis 15
und über 20
Idle
also mit minimaler Bestückung rede ich jetzt hier
nicht mit Magnetfestplatten die drehen und sowas
über 20 ist eigentlich schon ein bisschen viel
das ist so die Skala
die ich so ein bisschen im Kopf habe
Okay, dann gucken wir doch nochmal
Wenn einem das hier nicht schnell genug ist
Sagt der, der nicht weiß, was er für Strom bezahlt
Naja, eins weiß ich
Wenn ich weniger Strom verbrauche, bezahle ich auch weniger
In der Summe
Was ist das hier?
Bär bauen
Inventory
Wir hatten mal einen aus England
Der hat nicht Inventory gesagt
Der hat gesagt Inventory
Wie spricht man das eigentlich offiziell aus?
Pronunciation
Anscheinend spricht man das wirklich so aus
Inventory
Das spricht man wirklich so aus
Das spricht man nicht Inventory aus
Inventory
Fuck, der hat recht
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht, ein Englisch-Native-Speaker weiß, wie man das richtig ausspricht
Inventory
Ah, die Amis sprechen das Inventory aus
Die Engländer sprechen das Inventory aus.
Na gut.
Alles klar, haben wir wieder was gelernt, Leute.
Inventory ist Kona, Inventory ist UK.
Sirius Max, die Sachen scheinen auch gerade ein bisschen kaputt zu sein.
Im Discord kam auch keine Notification.
Okay, was wollen die hier zu sagen?
US Warehouse.
Okay, was ist da drin?
Okay, guck mal.
Wieder eine HS-CPU.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Genau, 8 Kerne Dings.
Bis zu 5,1.
Okay, das ist ein neuerer Ryzen als bei dem anderen.
Und auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr Power Efficient.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall richtig ordentliche CPU Power.
Aber das ganze Ding wird jetzt auch keinen sonderlich guten Eidelstromverbrauch haben.
Ich meine, das ist ein 0.
Was?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 0.
Wer hat sich denn diese Nummerierung ausgedacht?
Hätte man nicht wenigstens machen können.
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Vor allem 0.
Na gut.
Ist auch egal.
Ist nicht unser Problem.
Was haben wir denn hier?
6.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
6 mal Storage
5 mal
NVMe
Oh, das ist, das, das, das
Ding hat ordentlich Power
Aber, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, wofür ist denn denn der 0. Slot?
Ist das ein Fake Slot?
Oder was?
In einen Slot kommen die
NVMe, ach, die NVMe's
kommen da rein, ich hab gedacht, die kommen Onboard oder so
Ach, das hier ist für
NVMe dann, das ist da quasi so eine
so eine kleine Platine
drin für die NVMe ist, oder was?
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Okay, NAS Gaming ist wieder angesagt.
Was auch immer
die sich bei diesen Bildern denken.
Interface.
Introduction.
Okay, ja, das ist, da merkst du
auch gleich schon, Okulink.
Da merkst du gleich schon, das hat ein bisschen...
Moment, das hat wieder nur...
Ach nee, ah, hier, hier, Intel.
2x 10G. Das hat sogar
SFP+. Eine ziemlich alte
Netzwerkkarte hat es allerdings.
Moment, nee, warte mal. Die 7010
sind das die neuen oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ich glaube aber, die sind ziemlich alt, oder?
Ja, 2014.
Von 2014 ist dieser Chip.
Das heißt, es werden nicht die allersparsamsten
10 Gigs sein. Haben zumindest schon mal den Vorteil,
dass sie SFP+.
SFP ist ja in der Regel ein bisschen sparsamer als R45.
also was haben wir hier hier zweimal ssp plus also connectivity ist nice hätte das ding jetzt
noch ein pc express dort wäre das richtig bock die frage ist halt wie viel braucht das ding
eitel power consumption bei euch läuft werbung für youtube channel und twitch streamer in der
Uber. Ah ja, let's go.
Die sind halt
schon 2026
angekommen.
18 Watt Idle?
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist gar nicht mal
übel.
Für so ein fettes Ding.
Okay, ohne Scheiß.
Hätte das Ding jetzt noch
einen PCI-Express-Slot?
PCI-Express kannst du über
Okulink machen. Ja gut, dann hast du
irgend so ein Ding daneben stehen. Das ist doch auch Mist.
Also, hätte, wäre hier irgendwie noch so ein PCI-Express drin, wäre nice.
Aber das ist Hardware-technisch, ohne Mist, gar nicht mal übel.
Richtig fette CPU, ordentlich RAM, 5 NVMe, ECC-Support.
Ach, das waren die Dinger, die keinen Hotswap können, oder?
War da nicht was?
Ich hab doch auf Reddit gelesen, dass die keinen Hotswap können.
Dass NVMe nicht Hotswap ist, dachte ich mir.
Okay, es gibt es hier mit 48 Gig...
Oh, Leute, Rampreise schlagen zu.
Rampreise...
Aber das ist doch lächerlich.
Das ist doch lächerlich.
Ich meine, 500 Euro?
Okay, sag mal 400...
Nee. Sag mal 400 Euro.
400 Euro. So teuer ist ein 48G
gar nicht, oder? Oder ist das mittlerweile so teuer?
Geiz.
Hals.
SO-Dim.
Und...
ECC. Guck mal mal.
Bin ich blöd?
Wo ist das Speicher?
Ah, Chat.
Arbeitsspeicher.
RAM.
Speicher.
Okay.
ECC.
Wir gucken erst DDR5.
DDR5.
Dim.
Hallo?
The fuck?
Ach, hier muss man.
Tool-Eigenschaften.
Äh.
Warum kann ich das nicht filtern richtig?
Was ist denn mit der Geizhalsseite wieder los?
formfaktor ach so aber warum warum finde ich das mit es ohne ccc
nach was muss man also noch nicht ccc es odin etc
keine ahnung seit bernie cc
es gibt auch nicht viele hersteller davon
okay boah fucking shit aller da ist das weg da fuck
Boah, ist das teuer
Meine Fresse
Alter, ist das teuer
Hahaha
Ach du Scheiße, Mann
Ach du Scheiße
Von 157 Euro
auf 674.
Alter. Dann ist das preislich
sogar fair. Guck mal.
Das ist, wenn ich mir das
hier kaufen würde, 48
Gig.
Da gibt es nur einen.
Das ist sogar noch teurer.
Das Schlimmste, das lohnt sich sogar.
Also lohnen würde ich es jetzt nicht unbedingt nennen.
Ja, aber das
würde sich, ne, also
ihr wisst was ich meine.
Das wäre doch billiger als selbst kaufen.
WTF, Alter,
ist das teuer.
Ramschucking.
Da wäre ich dabei.
Leider sind die Hersteller nicht doof.
Also man,
ich habe jetzt schon immer mal Just for Fun
auf Ebay geguckt, ja,
nach alter Server-Hardware,
ob die da noch RAM drin haben, ja.
Was ist hier?
Ein DL380 oder irgendwie sowas
Aber
Die meisten Dinger
Sind schon gerammt
Guck mal hier
32 GB RAM
Das sind aber alte
Das ist bestimmt noch DDR3 oder irgendwie sowas
Was für ein RAM ist es?
32 GB RAM
Da sieht man nicht was
Okay, das könnte tatsächlich...
Was hat denn der HP DL38 Gen 9?
Ich bin ramm drinnen.
DDR?
DDR4?
Oh!
Chat!
Guck mal!
Hier ist DDR4 ECC RAM 32 Gig drin.
Da könnte man den RAM schrucken, Alter.
Gleich mal bei Geizhals gucken, was das kostet.
RAM schrucken oder nach dem Server einfach für 5 Euro noch verkaufen.
Ähm.
Ich bin wieder zu blöd, das hier zu sehen.
Arbeitsspeicher?
Okay, machen wir mal.
Aber das ist nicht S0-Dim, ne?
Das ist normaler.
Das ist normaler ECC-RAM.
Wir brauchen ja SO-DIMM.
Aber gucken wir trotzdem mal kurz hier.
DDR4, ECC.
Kann sich das mal...
ECC.
Und jetzt sagen wir mal hier 32...
32 Gig pro Modul.
Oder ne, sind das pro Modul?
Weiß man jetzt gar nicht.
Schauen wir mal.
Naja.
Ne, ne, ne.
Das lohnt sich nicht.
Lohnt sich nicht.
Nope.
Sind wir bei 140 Euro für 32 Gig.
Lohnt sich nicht.
Die CPU kann doch nur DDR3.
Ja, dann ist es komplett für den Arsch.
Dann lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht.
Ja.
Also ich habe jetzt schon öfters mal geguckt.
Ich habe bis jetzt auch noch nichts gefunden, wo sich das irgendwie lohnt.
Das ist halt echt sadge, ne?
Ramschucken.
Wenn man so sucht,
DDR5 ECC
SO-Dim,
da wirst du wahrscheinlich nur super teures
Sven überhaupt finden.
Was ist das?
Äh.
Das ist ein Schnapper, oder?
Ah, das ist kein ECC.
Das ist kein...
Oder? Sicher, dass das ECC ist?
Ich glaube, der Typ, der weiß nicht, was er schreibt.
Das ist kein ECC, stimmt's?
Nee, das ist kein ECC.
Das ist...
Das ist Chebat.
Das ist kein ECC.
Guck, das ist auch kein ECC.
Die Chebaten einfach ganz hart.
Also, Chat, wenn das ECC wäre, würde das doch garantiert draufstehen, oder?
Und man hätte hier in der Mitte irgendwas noch.
Stimmt, DDR5 hat dieses InBand oder wie das heißt.
Oder wie sowas, ECC, ja.
Ja, okay.
Aber das ist natürlich doof.
Tja.
Skamast wird man hier.
Aber das ist eine coole Hardware.
Leute, ich sag euch, ich werd's mir nicht kaufen.
Ich brauch nicht noch
ein Nass. Ich brauch nicht noch eins.
Was dann hier rumsteht.
Chat, wisst ihr, was mir gerade so einfällt?
Guck mal.
Hier hast du 5 NVMe-Slots.
Du hast hier welche?
PCI-Express 4,
X2x1, X2x2.
Da könnte man doch,
theoretisch,
wenn man unbedingt
einen PCI-Express-Slot haben möchte,
man könnte sich hier
einen Adapter holen. Es gibt Adapter
M2
auf PCI Express.
Gibt es.
Gibt es Adapter.
Nicht das hier.
Aber die gibt es.
Die Suche ist nur einfach
zu dumm.
Da ging er... So was hier in der Richtung.
Ja.
Da gibt es Adapter.
Adapter.
Und ich brauche nicht schlauer das Ding jetzt.
Also da gibt es Adapter und auch welche, die jetzt nicht ganz so billig wirken.
Da könnte man vielleicht, wenn man hier im Gehäuse noch Platz hat,
sich wirklich eine PC-Express-Karte reinpappen.
gibt es gibt es das irgendwie von innen sieht man das irgendwie von innen tier
dauern moment da muss jetzt mal kurz gucken ich weiß ich bin super super
sidetracked
man sieht es nicht von innen oder
Also, Chad, wenn man es wirklich drauf anlegen will, könnte man.
Aber dass die NVMe-SSDs halt auf so einem Tray sitzen, ist halt auch blöd, ne?
Ne, die NVMe-SSDs kommen da rein, hier unten.
Die kommen gar nicht auf den Tray.
Da könnte man, also wenn man es wirklich drauf anlegt, könnte man hier einen Adapter reinpacken, M2 auf PCI Express und dann könnte man sich mit einem Dremel oder so irgendwie hier ein Loch in die Seite schneiden und da die PCI Express Karte rausgucken lassen, falls man das haben will.
Falls man nur eine interne braucht, noch besser.
Aber die X710 sind ja auch nicht die neuesten Karten.
Also das aller stromsparendste ist es nicht.
Wobei die getestet haben, angeblich 10 Watt Eidel.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie die...
Ne, nicht 10 Watt Eidel. 18 Watt Eidel.
Wobei ich halt nicht weiß, ob sie das mit der 10 Gig Karte drin hatten.
Wofür brauchst du PCI Express?
Zum haben.
Weil ich das haben will.
Brauchen tue ich das nicht.
Aber wie wir das haben, ist besser als brauchen.
Nur eine von den fünf ist unten.
Nee, in dem Video eben hat man doch gesehen,
dass da...
Ach so, ja, eine. Hast recht.
Hast recht, eine. Das da oben war der RAM.
Ich hab mich verguckt.
Ich hab mich verguckt, das war der RAM.
Ja, das hier war der RAM. Ja, aber das macht doch nichts.
Nimmst du halt die da unten. Ist doch auch okay.
Äh.
Und hier sieht es so aus, als
sollte da mal
eine hin?
kommen?
Ist aber nicht.
Oder ist doch.
Ist das hier nochmal ein M2?
M2?
By the way,
warum glitzert die Seite hier?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Weil Ostern ist.
Chat, was sagt denn der Chat?
Ah ja, alles klar.
Das muss ich jetzt unbedingt wissen.
Also Chat, ich hab eigentlich keinen Bock nochmal 1109.
Was ist denn das gerade?
In Euro.
Passt 1 zu 1, oder?
Also ich hab keinen Bock nochmal 962 Euro auszugeben, um mir ein weiteres Nas zu kaufen.
Dann hätte ich 5 Nasses daheim.
Das bringt's ja dann richtig.
Ist das eine Real-Technik?
Ne, Intel.
Das heißt, die sind auch gut supported.
Intel.
Zweimal Intel X710.
Okay, ich sehe, da steht
Oculink drin, das kann man wohl anklicken.
Oculink Graphics Dock
Development Mod.
Ja, das wäre natürlich auch sinnig.
Das wäre natürlich aussehnlich.
Da müsste man es über Okulink
irgendwie intern...
Ja, also eigentlich...
Eigentlich hat man ja mit Okulink
jetzt den Vorteil,
man könnte
noch ein PCI-Express...
By the way,
wo kriegt man denn dann den Strom überhaupt her?
Ich dachte,
Okulink macht auch Strom, aber anscheinend nicht.
Warum hat das
so viele Anschlüsse?
Naja.
Gut, jetzt sind wir lange genug sidetracked worden.
Von, ähm,
Wallboxen zu weiteren
Nassgeräten und sonst was.
Aber wieder cool, was wir da so alles gesehen haben.
Es mir juckt schon wieder
in den Fingern, mir noch ein Nass zu kaufen, Leute.
Ich bin richtig dumm, oder?
Aber ich kaufe mir das nicht. Nein, ich werde es mir nicht kaufen.
Es ist total hängen geblieben.
Ich brauche überhaupt keine 5 Nasses.
Wozu?
Wozu brauche ich 5 Nasses?
Das ist reiner Spieltrieb.
Reiner Spieltrieb.
Nichts, dass ich es irgendwie brauchen würde.
Wallbox für PCI Express.
Naja, vielleicht gibt es ja schon Wallboxen
mit einem Raspberry Pi 5
und da kannst du ja theoretisch PCI Express anschließen.
Leute, ich habe ein Problem.
Ich muss mal kurz
kann ich irgendwie den chat overlayen oder so wir machen das jetzt einfach so
auf klo gleich wieder da moment moment installiere toilet das ist übrigens kein
gag weil ich mal aufs klo muss das absicht auto mod hat eine nachricht geblockt ja zu
recht hat die nachricht geblockt ich hätte ich muss mal kurz jemand bannen
exzellent wenn
und da ist er gewarnt
Ähm.
Echo.
Aff, Klo.
Gleich wieder da.
Gepiped nach Toilet.
Zack.
Na, das kann man ja aber kaum lesen.
Gibt's da nicht einen besseren Font?
Rainbow.
Exzellent.
das kann aber keiner lesen dass der afg lo steht probier was man damit aus weiß
gar nicht wie man da die schriftarten ändert mehr umprobieren vor auf form aufs
klo gehen als das klo gehen dann dauert okay afg lo hier auf klo gleich wieder
da haben wir noch mal ein paar leer zeichen da werden auf klo gleich wieder
jetzt kann man es lesen und das ganze wird jetzt gepreist nach
wie ist dieses programm noch mal um alles es gab das programm wo man wo man
die ganzen sachen so regenbogen farben mäßig machen kann
lolcat hieß das genau lolcat auch noch
jetzt haben wir die allerwichtigsten sachen am start
das kann ich auch aufs klo gehen excellent oder
oh
kanns nicht
Okay, bester Chat.
Jetzt kann ich mal aufs Klo gehen. Bis gleich.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Vertraue und glaube, es hilft, es heilt die göttliche Kraft!
Vielen Dank.
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
Excellent.
Übrigens.
Oh, ist die Musik fertig?
Oder ist die abgekackt?
Oder?
Ah.
Übrigens, das finde ich so nice hier.
Da mache ich jetzt gleich mal ein Bash-Kommando draus.
Gehe mal hier rein.
Waren wir hier?
Hier.
Abklo?
So.
Ups.
Kann ich Abklo tippen? Guck mal.
Ist das nicht nice?
Jetzt habe ich ein
Abklo-Kommando.
Moment, das können wir noch verbessern.
Das können wir noch verbessern.
Wir machen noch einen Clear.
Clear.
Exzellent!
Da habe ich fürs nächste Mal schon gleich vorgesorgt. Da weiß jeder, dass ich Affklo bin.
So, also auf geht's. Chatgear, was habe ich verpasst?
Hintergrund im Terminal setzen. Ja, man kann es auch beliebig ex...
Wieso, was kostet das? 15.000 Euro?
Oh ne, geht ja so
Was soll das denn sein?
Mit noch Tourlüftern drin
Äh, und wo genau kommen da jetzt die Platten rein?
Ich seh da überhaupt keine
Da ist überhaupt kein Platz für Platten drin
Wo soll das nass sein?
Nee, sehe ich jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Irgendwie alles Konkurrenz dazu.
Welches NAS ist für Einsteiger gut geeignet?
Das Wichtigste, was du machen musst, ist, bevor du dich für irgendeine Hardware entscheidest,
sei es NAS, irgendwelche anderen Homelab Equipment und sonst was.
Überleg dir, wofür du es kaufst.
Kaufst du sie hauptsächlich als Netzwerkspeicher?
Kaufst du sie hauptsächlich zum Rumbasteln, irgendwelche eigenen Software-Sachen drauf laufen zu lassen?
Kaufst du dir vielleicht, willst du dir vielleicht sogar was kaufen für Hardware-Automatisierung-Sachen?
Da ist ein Raspberry Pi wahrscheinlich besser geeignet.
Kaufst du dir was für, willst du viele VMs laufen lassen oder willst du irgendwie 20 Services in irgendwelchen Containern laufen lassen?
Also was ist der Grund, warum du dir das nass kaufst?
Davon würde ich ein bisschen abhängig machen, was ich mir kaufe.
Ansonsten, als Einsteigergerät, ganz ehrlich, ich finde...
Ich finde das Ding hier echt... Achso, Moment.
Und was ich noch fragen muss ist, willst du das verwenden fertig so wie es ist?
Oder willst du da selbst darauf was installieren?
Also willst du zum Beispiel das NAS einfach nur anstöpseln und als Netzwerkspeicher verwenden können?
oder willst du dann erst mal selbst in linux drauf installieren und sachen einrichten das
ist so vielleicht weil sie grundsätzlich sein wenn du ein fertiges nass willst was du anstöpselt und
benutzen kannst da kannst du auch mit irgendeinem technology oder q-nap oder so fix und fertig okay
ja dann kannst du das was wir hier im stream gerade besprochen haben und machen und tun und
hin und her kann sich noch mal vergessen da geht es ja immer um selbst einrichten ganz ehrlich fix
unfertiger Netzwerkspeicher.
Habe ich mir noch nie gekauft.
Kann ich nicht so sagen. Aber ich glaube,
für diese Zwecke reiner Netzwerkspeicher
und ganz
gutes Softwarepaket, da ist
Synology wahrscheinlich immer noch das Beste, was man
machen kann. Was mir
bei Synology halt nicht gefällt ist,
Synology ist für die
für die
Performance der Hardware, die man bekommt,
ist es eigentlich zu teuer.
Aber dafür bekommst du die mit
Abstand beste so out of the box
Lösungen, die es gibt.
Von der Software
und wie einfach es zu benutzen ist.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
So nach dem Motto
10 Jahre Homeoffice.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Wann war Corona?
2020 oder so?
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Wann war
Ja, dann 6 Jahre
Homeoffice könnte ich ein Video machen
Ja
Das ist eine gute Idee
Das wäre glaube ich auch mal wirklich wieder ein gutes
Einstiegsvideo, ja
6 Jahre Homeoffice
Aber vorher müsste ich eigentlich
auch mal ein Was ist los Video machen
dass die Leute
Ja, haben wir uns vorhin schon angeguckt.
Also wir hatten uns vorher eine andere Statuspage angeguckt.
Und da waren die unter 90% Uptime.
Das ist halt echt mies, ja.
Wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt.
Warum keine Videos mehr kommen, weil ich sie nicht mehr alle habe.
Die Zusammenfassung.
Als TLDR.
Hardware ist auch eingeschränkt bei Synology.
Nee, das haben die doch zurückgerudert, oder?
Haben die da nicht zurückgerudert?
Mit, ähm, welche Platten man verwenden darf?
Evendor Login Platten.
Da haben die doch zurückgerudert, oder?
Bilde ich mir ein.
Moment, Moment.
Synology
Hardware
Login
Hier, Synology nimmt Festplattenherstellersperre
wieder zurück
Ja genau, das war auch mein letzter Stand
Wir haben noch immer Kompatibilitätsliste
Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass eine andere nicht funktioniert, oder?
Dass sie nur Sachen, wo sie halt selbst getestet haben
Ach, machen sie das?
Okay.
Eine Balkonsolaranlage mit maximaler Laufklasse kostet 250 Euro.
Aber ich habe keinen Balkon.
Wo soll ich das denn hinstellen?
Auf die Terrasse oder so?
Das einzige Gute bei mir wäre wirklich das Dach.
Aber das wird zu teuer, um mal ein bisschen zu basteln.
Im Garten?
Ja, Balkonkraftwerke sind auch dafür gemacht, um die an Geländer,
ja doch, quasi vorne so rauszuhängen aus dem Balkon, oder?
Die kann ich doch nicht einfach auf die Terrasse stellen oder so.
Auf die Garage.
Auf die Garage könnte ich stellen.
Aber da müsste ich ja irgendwie den Strom quer durchs Hof legen oder so.
Nee, das ist nix.
Direkt aufs Auto.
Das wäre eine gute Sache, ja.
Wie ein Spoiler.
Ja, vorne dran dann.
Vorne dran ans Auto.
Oder hinten. Oder oben hinten.
Ah, ich bin da.
Moin. Guck mal, Jando ist am Start.
Ich glaube nicht.
Also, ich kann es
nicht auf die Garage machen.
Weil die Garage müsste ich dann irgendwie
ein Stromkabel quer durch den Hof legen. Das ist Mist.
Der Stall hat ein schräges Dach.
Und da muss ich auch irgendwie
den Strom dran bekommen.
Aufs Hausdach geht nicht.
Aber auf die Terrasse kommt zu wenig
Sonne.
Balkonkraftwerk.
Nein, nicht Kraftwerk.
Solaranlage.
Wie viel Quadratmeter hast du?
Oh, einige.
Genau weiß ich es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Aber das ist einiges.
Also das Grundstück ist relativ groß.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt kein Villa mit 1000 Hektar Land oder so.
Aber das ist ein Haus mit zwei Stockwerken.
Das ist ein Stall
Eine Garage
Und ein Gartenhaus
Gartenhäuschen, Gartenhütte
Eher ein Haus, Gartenhütte
Ähm
Und drum herum halt
Dann Garten
Der Garten
Also der Garten ist größer als
Das wo das Haus drauf steht
Das ist schon relativ groß
Ich kann dir die Quadratmeter insgesamt nicht sagen
Also, ich gehe davon aus, wenn ich das verkaufen würde in der heutigen Zeit, würde ich wahrscheinlich nochmal richtig fett Kohle bekommen.
Sonneneinschreinung auf der Garage, die dürfte ganz gut sein.
Ich hatte, Garage habe ich noch nicht geguckt, aber ich glaube, ich habe es mal so aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen.
Ich habe mal so eine Sonneneinfalls-Dings-Karte aufgehabt für mein Grundstück.
Da war Dach das Beste und Garage war, glaube ich, auch ganz okay.
Kannst du Verlängerungen durch den Garten legen?
Nee, das ist doch doof.
Da liegt dann ein Kabel rum.
Und beim nächsten Mal Rasen mähen, mach ich's kaputt, oder was?
Oder meinst du, ich soll eine Verlängerung
verbuddeln?
Ja, ich glaube, auf der Seite
hab ich geguckt, Chainlaw. Ich glaub, das ist das.
Da sieht man das.
Wobei, nee, nee, nee.
Nicht ganz sicher, ob das das ist. Doch, doch, doch.
warte mal ich gehe mal das gold hat mal rein ja doch das ist es das ist das ich
hatte aber auch noch so sagt noch so eine seite da konnte man quasi so
reinmalen wo man die solaranlage hinsetzen will und irgendwie mit
neigung und da hat sie ausgerechnet wie viel sonnen du so stunden pro jahr
kriegst du sowas
Das könnte es gewesen sein.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ja, also wenn ich es hinten
auf die Gartenhütte machen würde,
da ist tatsächlich
kein Baum in der Nähe,
ordentliche Sonneneinstrahlung,
da müsste ich eine Verlängerung legen
von der Gartenhütte quasi
vorne hin aber da sind dahinter habe ich kein wlan empfang die das ding soll doch
bestimmt ins wlan oder weil wie mache ich denn sonst am besten
evcc ach das keine ahnung ich glaube wenn ich mir eine solaranlage hinbau
dann muss die aufs dach und dann wird es halt richtig teuer und da habe ich
aktuell noch gar keinen bock drauf
ist das denn
Ja, das ist doch auch Blödsinn, ne?
Kannst dein Dach auch vermieten als Solarfläche, was es nicht alles gibt, oder?
Ja, nee, nee, nee, das wird mir gerade auch zu teuer alles, nee.
Also so ein Balkonkraftwerk fände ich ganz cool, wenn ich eine gute Stelle, wo ich es hinschließen kann, anschließen kann und halt auch eine gute Stelle, wo ich dann das Stromkabel nicht irgendwie einmal quer durchs Grundstück legen muss.
Balkonkraftwerk für Gartenhütte.
Gartenhütte.
Gartenhausmodell.
Ihr Praxisguide.
Okay.
Also das...
Meine Hütte ist eher...
eher rund.
Um Rasenmähen einfach einrollen.
Nee, das ist mir zu doof.
Das sind wieder irgendwelche dummen Webseiten.
Das ist eher eine Hundehütte, oder?
EVCC muss man auf GitHub gucken, da ist es besser.
Ach nee, das ist auch keine gute Erklärung.
Das ist hier.
Ein Home Energy Management System.
Da kannst du dann gucken, wann lohnt sich dein Auto zu laden,
wie viel ist der Batteriestand.
Da hast du quasi Übersicht über deine
selbst erzeugte Energie und was du so verbrauchst
und rausziehst. Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Habe ich aber nicht im Einsatz.
Weil ich habe halt ein Elektroauto,
aber keinerlei Solarpanels.
Ja, aber ich weiß ja gar nicht, wo ich es hinstellen soll.
Das ist ja...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin ja bei sowas Basteldingern
bin ich ja immer dabei.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie ich es hinstellen soll.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal.
Hat nicht einer gesagt, das neue Morpheus-Video ist nicht schlecht hier?
Warum wollen sie wirklich alle Rechenzentren im All?
Ja, also ich hab ehrlich gesagt
Gar nicht mitbekommen, dass Leute Rechenzentrum
Im Weltall wollen
Dann erzähl uns das mal
GTC GPUs fürs Weltall
Angekündigt, Rechenzentren im
Orbit und auf den ersten Blick ergibt das
Perfekt Sinn, das Weltall ist
Ups, oh
Jetzt hab ich Mist geklickt
Jetzt hab ich
Das Video zerstört
Hallo
Peace.
Ja, man hat so Übertragungsmöglichkeiten, ne?
Kein Medium zu übertragen, genau.
Deswegen, ich bin ganz sicher, ob das so einfach ist, da Sachen zu kühlen im Weltall.
Also, ab ins All damit.
Klingt smart.
Ich muss zugeben, mein erster Gedanke war klar, natürlich, logisch, kalt da oben, perfekt für Server.
Aber eure Thermoskanne, die hier ist keine, aber Kaffee hält sie trotzdem warm.
Warum?
Weil in einer Thermoskanne Vakuum ist.
Ja, das ist genau das erste, woran ich auch gedacht habe.
Es leitet Wärme nicht ab, es hält sie fest.
Selbe Physik.
Und genau diese Physik herrscht im Weltraum vor.
Und trotzdem wollen Nvidia, Google, SpaceX alle gleichzeitig...
Die hatten doch auch schon mal Unterwasser, ein Rechenzentrum Unterwasser und so.
Das haben die jetzt, glaube ich, ja auch mittlerweile wieder außer Betrieb genommen.
...alle mit ihren Grafikkarten.
Die Milliarden fließen mal wieder.
Entweder sind die alle dumm, was ich nicht glaube,
oder Kühlung war eigentlich gar nicht der eigentliche Grund.
Aber warum eigentlich?
Um das zu verstehen, müssen wir tatsächlich auf die Erde gucken.
Denn genau hier liegt das eigentliche Problem, vor dem sie weglaufen wollen.
KI-Computation-Power verdoppelt sich nicht einfach.
Sie vervier- bzw. verfünffacht sich jedes Jahr.
Und deswegen sind die Rampreise so teuer.
Ah.
Das Stromnetz hingegen wächst kaum.
Neue Kraftwerke brauchen je nach Typ so vier bis acht Jahre, bis sie stehen.
Gartner sagt deshalb, bis 2027 werden geschätzte 40% aller KI-Rechenzentren durch den Strommangel eingeschränkt.
Nicht durch fehlende Chips, sondern durch den Strommangel.
Und bei uns sieht es nicht wirklich besser aus.
Also Frankfurt, zum Beispiel Deutschlands Rechenzentren-Hauptstadt, wenn ihr so wollt, wegen dem Dezix, ist Europas größter Internet-Knotenpunkt.
In Deutschland stammen allerdings 71% des Kühlwassers für Rechenzentren aus dem Trinkwassernetz.
Eurem Trinkwasser und meinem auch.
Die Rechenzentren konkurrieren deshalb mit der Stadt selbst um dieselbe Ressource.
Und genau deswegen protestieren Anwohner und Gerichte stoppen Neubauten von Rechenzentren.
Amsterdam hat auch ein Moratorium.
Das will ich sehen, ja.
Und Irland hat jahrelang auch Nein gesagt zu neuen Rechenzentren.
Weil in Frankfurt wird Laufenzeug gebaut.
Pause gemacht, ist es überall so.
Und die Tech-Industrie sagt deshalb, gehen wir einfach ins All.
Da kann uns niemand stoppen.
Was wie ein ganz normaler Dienstag bei SpaceX sich anhört, war halt auf der GTC plötzlich...
Was ich mir halt vorstelle ist, so Wartungsarbeiten im Weltall sind halt recht schwierig.
Wartungsarbeiten sind ja schon bei diesen Unterwasserrechenzentren schwierig.
Aber im Weltall?
Im Weltall ist es so, es ist was kaputt.
Und das heißt, wir lassen es einfach kaputt und haben hoffentlich Ersatz mit an Bord.
Am Montag auf der GTC, das ist Nvidias Konferenz, hat Nvidia Space One Vera Rubin vorgestellt.
Das ist ein Modul von GPUs, also Grafikkarten, fürs All.
Strahlungstolerant mit redundanter Berechnung gegen kosmische Strahlung.
Hierbei läuft dieselbe Berechnung auf zwei Chips gleichzeitig und die Ergebnisse werden danach verglichen und abgeglichen.
Bis zu 25 mal mehr KI-Rechenleistung als die H100 soll sie trotzdem haben für Inference im Orbit.
Nvidia hat sechs Launchpartner auf einmal.
Aetherflux, Axiom Space, Kepler, Planet Labs, Sophia Space und Starcloud.
Das Ganze übrigens benannt nach einer Astronomin, die starke Belege dafür geliefert hat, dass man Dinge nicht sehen muss, damit sie da sind.
Irgendwie ein sehr passendes Branding für eine Blackbox von KI im Orbit.
Egal. Gleichzeitig arbeitet Google an Project Suncatcher.
Das sind TPUs, also Tensor Processing Units, Karten speziell für KIs, auch im Orbit.
81 Satellitencluster sollen als Forschungsdesign dienen und Google hat angekündigt, bis 2027 TPUs im Orbit schon testen zu wollen.
Ey, ich warte echt noch drauf.
Mittlerweile haben wir da so viel Zeug rumschwirren.
Wenn da mal was kaputt geht, dann gibt es dann irgendwann so eine Kettenreaktion.
Das erste Ding geht kaputt, die Trümmer zerstören das zweite Ding,
die nächsten Trümmer zerstören die nächsten vier
und dann können wir nicht, kann ich nicht mehr ins Weltall fliegen,
weil nur noch Schrott unterwegs ist.
Noch nächstes Jahr dann, ne?
SpaceX hat bei der FCC ein Orbital Data Center System beantragt,
wo eine Million Satelliten zum Einsatz kommen sollen.
Ihr seht also, die Entwicklung ist nicht nur auf einer Seite, sondern auf sehr vielen gleichzeitig.
Und diese Entwicklung ist irre schnell.
Vor vier Monaten hat StarCloud One eine einzelne H100 ins All geschickt,
die etwa 60 Kilo wiegt und ungefähr so viel Rechenleistung hat wie mein Homelab.
Kleiner Spaß an der Stelle.
Darauf wurde das erste KI-Modell trainiert, das im Orbit trainiert wurde.
Und naja, mit der Space One Vera Rubin geht es natürlich jetzt nochmal in eine ganz andere Richtung.
Die größten Unternehmen der Erde denken sich also, gerade ist der perfekte Zeitpunkt, um die Erde zu verlassen.
Ich kann es ihnen nicht unbedingt immer verübeln, aber ich sitze hier und denke mir, wenn es nicht um Kühlung geht, worum geht es denn dann eigentlich?
Und falls euch jetzt gerade so ein bisschen mulmig wird, das ist...
Haben sie... Solarenergie oder was oder wie? Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es ihnen geht.
Im Zweifelsfall Überwachung und Daten sammeln.
Wenn ich auf irgendwas tippen müsste, ist es das.
Wie auch immer das im Weltall funktionieren soll, keine Ahnung.
Eine Rakete.
Eure Daten liegen in irgendeiner Cloud.
Ihr habt oftmals gar keine Ahnung, auf welchem Server, in welchem Land oder unter welchem Recht leider sogar manchmal.
Und bald liegt diese Cloud vielleicht noch nicht mal mehr auf der Erde.
Die einzige Infrastruktur, die ihr wirklich kontrolliert, die steht bei euch.
Und das Ding hat...
Auf diesem NAS kann ich alles spielen.
2,5 Ohnen Terminal.
Und dann...
Könnt ihr auch mal ausprobieren.
Das 6. NAS dann.
Und vielen Dank an Ugreen, dass ihr Videos wie dieses hier ermöglicht.
Und ja, mir ist selbstverständlich klar, wie das hier aussieht.
Ein Video über Rechenzentren...
Ach, Ugreen.
Ich hab mich verguckt.
Ich hab gedacht, es wäre das Ubiquiti NAS gewesen.
Ach so.
Ja gut, U-Creen habe ich ja schon jetzt zwei nasse.
Das reicht.
Schätke, was ist?
Ich würde mir gern ein Homelab holen.
Passt ein Barebone-PC mit einer N100-CPU?
Das passt.
Es kommt halt darauf an, was du machen willst.
Aber das ist nicht die neueste CPU.
Und die Plattform drunter ist auch nicht die neueste.
Aber wenn du da ein paar Container
und vielleicht die ein oder andere VMs laufen lassen möchtest,
dann tut das.
Also diese Mini-PCs sind preis-leistungsmäßig meistens gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist schon okay.
Was hat denn das?
Vier Cores, vier Threads.
Ja, also große Sprünge kannst du jetzt mit erzählen.
Also du musst jetzt nicht auf die Idee kommen, da irgendwelche lokale KI oder so drauf laufen zu lassen.
Aber ansonsten sind diese Dinger nicht verkehrt.
Was kostet sowas preislich?
Ja, das kannst du, guck mal hier, 150 Euro.
das kannst du machen.
Das finde ich
jetzt schon klar.
So ein Ding hier, ne?
Willst du dir holen. Was hast du denn da?
Zeig mal her. Du hast
Ich hab zwei U-Creamers, ja.
Im letzten Stream
haben wir sogar eins ausprobiert.
Aber ich benutze die ja nicht. Das ist ja das Dumme da dran.
Ich hab die nur aus Bastel, Basteltrieb.
Die haben keinen Rahmen. Ah ja, gut.
Nee, Rampreise muss halt immer eine Orbit drauf.
Aber es ist immerhin DDR4, das heißt, es ist ein bisschen günstiger.
Also so ein 16-Gig-Riegel DDR4, das ist schon noch erschwinglich.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist doch eine serielle Schnittstelle, oder?
Ja.
Okay, du hast eine...
Okay, die sind über SATA angebunden.
Und für Wi-Fi.
Okay, das ist...
Also sonderlich schnell ist das Ding nicht.
Aber einfach so ein bisschen basteln ist das, denke ich, okay.
Das ist nicht das gleiche Modell.
Was ist denn das gleiche? Das hier?
Das da?
naja
zweimal HDMI
wahrscheinlich eine 1Gb Netzwerkkarte
ein bisschen USB
ein Displayport
was hast du drinnen
2,5Gb sogar
zweimal M.2 Slots
ist halt die Frage
ob das SATA oder wirklich echte
PCI Express Anschlüsse sind
naja
Oh, SATA, okay.
Du hast zweimal PCI Express NVMe.
Also das sieht für mich jetzt vollkommen okay aus, ja.
So ein bisschen basteln, ist das okay.
Was für eine CPU genau hier?
Ja, das dürfte auch halbwegs stromsparend sein.
Ja, kann man denke ich nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen mit.
Also großartige
Nassgeschichten kannst du damit nicht machen
Ja
Genau, du kriegst ja keine Festplatten rein
Aber wenn du ein paar Container laufen lassen willst
Pappst du dir noch
SSDs bei rein
Die Scheiße ist halt, dass der RAM und die SSDs
halt deutlich teurer sind als die gesamte Kiste
Ne
Man kann auch tatsächlich
den M2 auf SATA adapteren. Das würde auch
funktionieren. Ja, das stimmt.
Chainlord, das was du da gepostet hast,
da ist bestimmt nicht der RAM mit drin.
Die unterstützen nur
so viel.
Oder?
Fragezeichen.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
512 GB.
SSD.
Ah, 12 GB, weil hier oben stand.
512 GB RAM.
Der kommt nicht mit RAM, oder?
Das ist natürlich, also wenn der mit 512 GB SSD und 12 GB RAM kommt, dann ist das preisleistungsmäßig hier in der Tat gar nicht so übel.
Aber das ist halt dieses AliExpress China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Da weißt du auch immer nicht, ob das stimmt.
Guck mal hier, das ist Blödsinn.
Das kostet am Ende 435 oder so, wenn du es wirklich bestellst.
AliExpress kannst du die angezeigten Preise immer komplett knicken.
So, jetzt gucken wir das Video erstmal weiter.
Sonst brauche ich da wieder so lange für.
Stand da Outdoor-Spaß? Wirklich?
Weil bei AliExpress steht teilweise übelste Blödsinn dran.
Im Weltraum gesponsert von einer Festplatte unter meinem Schreibtisch.
Aber genau das ist der Punkt.
Deshalb lasst uns...
Chat, da muss ich noch was zu sagen.
Den kenne ich nicht, aber mit Mikro-Tick machst du in der Regel nichts verkehrt.
Moment, Moment, was ist das Ding?
What the fuck?
Was ist denn das?
Ein MikroTik-Router auf einer PCI-Express-Karte?
Da läuft ein Router-OS auf der PCI-Express-Karte, oder wie?
sparen Sie Platz in Ihrem Serverraum,
indem Sie einen echten CR2004
im Server selbst... Ja?
Zweimal von... Das ist eine Netzwerkkarte
mit einem eigenen...
mit nochmal eigenen Hardware, wo
RouterOS draufläuft oder sowas.
Das ist ja abgedreht.
Preislich ist das natürlich Mikrotik-typisch
wahrscheinlich ganz gut,
weil ich absolut keine Vergleichswerte
zu sowas hier hab.
Irgendwie witzig
Was es nicht alles gibt
Ja
Ja, ist eine eigene
eigene CPU und so drauf
Was es nicht alles für Dinger gibt
Äh
Netzwerkkarte mit gutem Linux Support
Moment, willst du nur 25 Gig oder
tut es auch nur 10 Gig
Weil bei 10 Gig kannst du dir einfach
ältere Intel
10 Gig Intel Netzwerkkarten kaufen und die tun
Warum nicht?
Absinth zugefügt.
25G wäre schon geil.
Also ich habe jetzt gemerkt, wie schwierig es ist, überhaupt 10 Gig ordentlich auszulasten, weil die meisten SSDs, wenn du eine Weile drüber kopierst, gehen halt runter so auf 1,2, 1,3 Gigabyte die Sekunde.
wenn der Cache voll ist,
da bräuchtest du
einen
SSD-Rate
0 oder sowas.
Oder einen SSD-Rate, dass du
25 Gig
saturated kriegst.
Also was ist der Hintergrund?
Warum müssen es 25 Gig sein?
Das ist gar nicht so einfach,
10 Gig schon auszulasten.
Und 25 Gig stelle ich mir dann noch
deutlich aufwendiger vor.
Irgendwie geht das Emote nicht, oder? Kann das sein?
Doch, aber ich habe es hinzugefügt.
Ja, oder du machst alles auf deinem RAM-Disk.
250 GB RAM-Disk, easy.
Das ist in der heutigen Zeit bestimmt ganz sinnvoll.
So, aber jetzt müssen wir das Video fertig gucken, sonst kommen wir gar nicht mehr dahinter, was die im Weltall wollen und das dauert zu lang.
Was wir am allerbesten können. Ein Argument in ein bisschen mehr als 60 Sekunden zerlegen, allerdings in Netzwerksprache.
Ich bin kein Physiker, aber ich bin Informatiker und als Informatiker erkläre ich mir das Ganze so.
Stellt euch Wärme vor wie Netzwerktraffic. Euer Server produziert Wärme.
Das sind quasi Pakete, die raus wollen
Auf der Erde habt ihr drei Routen, wie wir wärmelos werden
Das kennen wir vielleicht von unseren Räumen mit den Gaming-PCs drin
In denen wir schon wieder 26 Grad haben, obwohl es draußen 10 hat
Für Wärme gibt es Leitungen
Das wäre dann sowas wie der direkte Kontakt zum Beispiel zur Luft
Dann wird die Luft einfach erwärmt
Wow, such news, ich weiß
Quasi aber ist das wie ein Ethernet-Kabel
Dann gibt es noch die Konvektion
Luft oder Wasser trägt die Wärme einfach weg, wie ein Switch, der Paket verteilt.
Es gibt aber auch sowas wie Funk, Strahlung.
Infrarotphotonen, die Wärme einfach abstrahlen.
5G, Keck Alu.
Quasi wie ein einzelnes, aber sehr langsames Funksignal.
Und jetzt schießt ihr den Server ins Vakuum.
Leitungen werden dort geblockt.
Luft gibt es da oben halt nicht so viel.
Dadurch ist auch die Konvektion geblockt.
Also sowas wie eine Firewall im Vakuum, die einen Drop auf jedes Wärmepaket macht.
Außer auf Strahlung. Strahlung funktioniert im All.
Aber Strahlung ist halt sowas wie ein 56K-Modem.
Es funktioniert, aber es ist wahnsinnig ätzend langsam.
Das Marketing spricht also hier ganz gerne von kostenloser Kühlung im Weltraum,
aber die Physik ist quasi ein Drop-All auf jedes Wärmepaket.
Und das ist das Gegenteil von kostenlos.
Kühlung wird im All ein neues Problem, das man davor nicht hatte.
Vakuum ist kein Kühler.
Vakuum ist eine Isolation.
Das ist auch das Erste, was ich mir gedacht habe.
Mindestens problematisch.
Aber lasst es mich einmal auf die Spitze treiben.
Und ich verspreche euch, die Zahlen machen gleich sehr viel Sinn.
Im Weltraum kann man durchaus kühlen über die erwähnte Strahlung.
Das geht schon.
Aber Strahlung braucht halt Fläche.
Sehr viel Fläche.
Also massive Radiatoren.
Was heißt das konkret?
Ein Megawatt Abwärme bei 300 Kelvin braucht ungefähr 2400 Quadratmeter Radiatorfläche.
Ich bin deutsch, also muss ich das umrechnen.
Fußballfelder, das ist ein Drittel eines Fußballfeldes.
Für ein einzelnes Megawatt.
Die ISS hat über 400 Quadratmeter Radiatoren für gerade mal 70 Kilowatt Wärme.
Ein modernes Rechenzentrum produziert hunderte Megawatt.
Skaliert das gerne hoch. Ich warte so lange.
So, und wenn jetzt ein Kühlradiator kaputt geht, dann viel Spaß mit dem Servicetechniker in 400 Kilometern Höhe.
Das ist also physikalischer ziemlicher Unsinn, ökonomisch durchaus fragwürdig und vor allem logistisch ein absoluter Albtraum.
Und trotzdem wollen Nvidia, Google und SpaceX schon ins All. Jetzt schon.
Also warum? Ich bin ehrlich mit euch, ich habe das anfangs wirklich für einen PR-Stunt gehalten.
Eine Art Schwanzvergleich unter Milliardären oder sowas.
Und dann habe ich mal ein bisschen tiefer gegraben und ich glaube, ich habe eine gewisse Antwort, die nichts mit Kühlung zu tun hat.
Also mein nächster Gedanke...
Wie findest du es, dass wir wieder zum Mond fliegen? Sehr nice, finde ich das.
Danke, mein Gedankengang einfach weiter.
Was ich bedenklicher finde, ist, dass sie Probleme mit Outlook haben im Weltall mittlerweile.
Ist ja gut, im All gibt es billigen Solarstrom und ja, der ist durchaus real.
Im All gibt es kein Wetter und keine Nacht, zumindest wenn man es richtig macht.
Die Sonne scheint dort oben quasi durchgängig und ein Solarpaneel im All liefert durchaus grob drei bis fünfmal so viel Energie wie auf der Erde.
Strom ist also quasi erstmal günstiger, aber der Strom ist halt von mir aus günstig oder gratis, die Lieferung ist es aber nicht.
Ein Kilo Hardware ins All zu bringen, kostet heute über 1000 Dollar und noch mehr Emissionen natürlich.
Google sagt, damit sich Rechenzentren im Orbit lohnen, müsste der Preis auf 200 Dollar oder tiefer pro Kilogramm fallen.
Eine ESPI-Studie setzt die Schwelle sogar nochmal drunter an.
Elon Musk verspricht für Starship, dass das Ganze am Ende 20 Dollar kosten soll.
Das ist sein Versprechen wohlgemerkt.
Gut, der erzählt ja viel, wenn er einen Tag lang ist, also da bin ich noch skeptisch.
Nicht die heutige Realität.
Leute, wenn ich für 20 Euro ein Kilogramm ins Weltall schicken kann, dann mache ich das auch.
Dann schicken wir auch was ins Weltall.
Trotzdem fließen schon heute die Milliarden.
Die Rechnung muss also irgendwo anders durchaus jetzt schon aufgehen.
Denn die Milliarden fließen ja, weil der Orbit die letzte Jurisdiktion ist,
in der niemand Nein sagen kann.
NWD verkauft die Chips an jeden dieser Player.
Egal ob jetzt SpaceX, Google, Axiom oder das Pentagon.
Und den interessiert jetzt nicht unbedingt, wer gewinnt, solange eben beide Seiten in Kuda schreiben.
Und genau hier musste ich an Sealand denken.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt, aber das war Haven Co. im Jahr...
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das war eine Ölbohrinsel, wo dann irgendein Typ gesagt hat...
Also ich... Mal gucken, ob ich das richtig zusammenkriege.
Da hat irgendein Typ gesagt, das sind ja internationale Gewässer.
Und deswegen ist das jetzt mein Königreich.
Und dann war er irgendwie der König von Sealand oder sowas.
Also quasi eine Ölboinsel mit nix.
Ja, und da wurden Server gehostet.
Für fragwürdige Inhalte.
2000. Das war eine Plattform in der Nordsee.
Sehr rostig, ein paar Leitungen und vor allem ein Generator.
Und vor allem ein Traum, eine Serverfarm zu bauen, die nicht wirklich reguliert werden konnte.
Acht Jahre und dann war Schluss.
Professor Grimmelmann von Cornell hat das Ganze analysiert.
analysiert. Haven Co. ist nicht an externen Druck gescheitert, es ist eigentlich an sich selbst zerbrochen. Zu wenig eigenes Recht, zu viel Abhängigkeit von der Infrastruktur an Land. Die Plattform war an sich unangreifbar, aber das Geschäftsmodell war es nicht. Und in diesem Fall sind jetzt die Server nicht irgendwo auf einem Wasser, sondern in 400 Kilometer Höhe. Und der Betreiber wird auf sehr viel reicher geschätzt. Den jagst du nicht, der jagt dich. Sealand war dagegen natürlich ein Witz.
Kein Gericht kann einen Server beschlagnahmen, der sich mit 28.000 Stundenkilometern über dem Horizont bewegt.
Und der Betreiber ist nicht irgendein Typ auf einer rostigen Plattform in der Nordsee, sondern halt ein Milliardenkonzern.
Und trotzdem, auf dem Papier gilt die DSGVO übrigens sogar im Orbit.
Auf dem Papier gilt auch der AI Act, aber wie willst du das durchsetzen?
Da oben wird es schwierig. Da oben kann man kein Audit durchführen und keine Inspektion durchführen.
Stellt euch vor, eure nächste Chatschibiti-Anfrage wird halt nicht in Frankfurt verarbeitet, sondern im Orbit.
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich nicht merken, die Latenz ist sowieso riesig bei KI-Sachen und deswegen fällt es auch nicht auf, wenn es halt mal ein paar hundert Millisekunden länger dauert.
Die Cookie-Banners fragen euch auch nicht.
Und naja, niemand kontrolliert, ob diese Datenschutzerklärung so wirklich stimmt.
Es gibt übrigens sogar einen, jetzt haltet euch fest, EU-Space-Act.
Der soll so ungefähr 2030 kommen, also vielleicht.
Der Entwurf regelt dann Startlizenzen, Haftung und hat durchaus sogar ein paar Cyberanforderungen dabei,
aber eben keine konkreten Regeln für Datenverarbeitung im Orbit.
Und ich habe beruflich IT-Sicherheitsaudits gemacht.
Manchmal muss man dafür vor Ort sein und kontrollieren, was auf dem Server eigentlich passiert.
Meine Frage jetzt, wie auditiert man einen Server, der alle 90 Minuten die Erde umkreist?
Und falls jemand denkt, ist ja egal, die Server sind verschlüsselt.
2022 hat Russland ein europäisches Satellitennetzwerk gehackt, wie er es hat.
Dabei gingen 5800 deutsche Windturbinen offline,
allerdings nicht, weil sie angegriffen wurden,
sondern weil sie halt aus Versehen am selben Netz hingen.
Die Schwachstelle an sich war eine VPN-Lücke an einer Bodenstation.
Der Weltraumvertrag an sich wurde allerdings 1967 geschrieben,
um Atomwaffen auf dem Mond zu verhindern,
nicht um irgendwelche verschlüsselten Datenströme zu regulieren.
Jurisdiktion folgt der Registrierung. Wer den Satelliten startet, bestimmt das anwendbare Recht.
Die allermeisten Staaten sind offensichtlich amerikanisch, das heißt überall dort gilt das US-Richt.
Und US-Richt hat natürlich den Cloud Act, den kennt ihr ja schon.
Dementsprechend wird es mit dem Datenschutz im Orbit eher schwierig.
Aber trotzdem, natürlich braucht man für ein Datenzentrum im Orbit keine Baugenehmigung.
Und genau das ist jetzt hier der Punkt, der mich seit ein paar Wochen durchaus schon beschäftigt.
Ist das der eigentliche Grund, warum man hier schon so viel Geld investiert?
Und naja, irgendwann habe ich mir das Ganze aufgeschrieben.
Nach der SpaceX-X-AI-Fusion kontrolliert Elon Musk Starship, also den Launch,
Starlink, also 65% aller aktiven Satelliten, X-AI und GROK, die KI,
und die geplante Millionen-Satelliten-Konstellation ja auch.
Und X, also die Plattform, auf der man sich über sowas beschweren könnte oder würde,
kontrollieren sie natürlich auch noch mit.
Seit der Fusion Anfang 2026 ist also quasi das Allermeiste unter einem Dach.
Eine Art Monopol mit Raketenzugang.
Für uns ist aber am Ende egal, ob das jetzt Musk, Bezos oder Pichai sind.
Das Problem ist, dass eine Person das Allermeiste davon kontrolliert.
Und naja, die EU ist irgendwie immer noch nicht zu finden.
Amazon hat übrigens sogar bei der FCC Beschwerde eingereicht.
SpaceX würde ein Orbital Monopoly bauen und würde damit zum Gatekeeper fürs All werden.
Und genau an dem Punkt wird es tatsächlich mal wieder geopolitisch.
Axiom Space hat am 11. Januar die ersten zwei Orbital Data Center Nodes gestartet.
Also für nationale Sicherheit, Echtzeitverarbeitung von Sensor- und Sicherheitsdaten,
Drohnenfeeds, Überwachung und autonome Entscheidungen.
Das ist jetzt also schon ein Move weg von kommerziell hin zu militärisch.
Aetherflux baut Galactic Brain, einen orbitalen...
Die Namen immer meine Dinger, ey.
KI-Knoten inklusive Energieübertragung vom All zur Erde per Infrarotlaser.
Und ja, auch China ist natürlich am Start.
Die bauen eine Satellitenkonstellation, die nennt sich Free Body.
Der gleichnamige Roman handelt übrigens davon, dass eine fremde Zivilisation die Erde bedroht.
Sehr subtil.
SpaceX schreibt dabei in einem FCC-Antrag wörtlich, das alles sei der erste Schritt zu einer Kaderschaft-2-Zivilisation.
Eine Zivilisation, die die gesamte Energie ihres Sterns nutzt.
Der Sonne, ja. Das ist natürlich Bullshit. Blablabla, ja.
Wir sind noch nicht mal Level 1.
Das schreiben sie in einem Antrag über Funkfrequenzen.
Und naja, wie gesagt, Europa hat natürlich mal wieder keinen Plan in der Hinsicht.
Deutschland hat 5,4 Milliarden Euro an die ESA überwiesen.
Das ist Europas größter Einzelbeitrag.
Damit baut Europa Iris 2, 290 Satelliten für Konnektivität, also Internet, reines Internet.
Trotzdem immerhin etwas, aber an sich keine Rechenleistung, keine KI natürlich.
Und die Bundesregierung antwortet auf die Frage, ob da KI drauf soll, einfach nur nein.
Also kein, wir überlegen oder wir überprüfen, ob sowas überhaupt nötig ist.
Weiß nicht.
Trotzdem gilt bei der ITU, wer zuerst kommt, malt zuerst.
SpaceX hat eine Million Plätze reserviert, China hat 200.000 Plätze reserviert.
Europa überlegt in diesem Fall noch, ob sie überhaupt hinfahren sollen.
Nvidia liefert Chips, SpaceX die Raketen und Axiom liefert dann ans Pentagon.
Und China baut natürlich alles als eigenes.
Das Ganze ist also sehr viel mehr geworden,
kann man dann bei AliExpress kaufen,
als nur eine Firma, die irgendwas liefert.
Satellit as a Service.
Es ist wirklich schon eine Art Ökosystem, beziehungsweise eine Industrie, die sich da aufbaut.
Und diese Industrie hat leider einen Preis, der nicht in Dollar bezahlt wird.
Also zumindest nicht von den Verursachern davon.
Forscher der University of Regina Princeton und der University of British Columbia haben die sogenannte Crash Clock entwickelt.
Alter, wo sucht der das immer raus, Alter?
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wo ich danach suchen soll, nach so Infos.
Wie lange dauert es eigentlich im Low Earth Orbit bis zur katastrophalen Kollision, wenn niemand ausweicht?
Ja, da habe ich mir tatsächlich auch schon Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Und ich habe da auch mal bei Urknall Weltall und das Leben, heißt der Kanal.
Übrigens kann ich nur empfehlen, da mal reinzugucken.
Da habe ich mal einen Vortrag zu gesehen, wo es auch darum ging,
ab einer gewissen Anzahl von Satelliten ist wohl das Problem,
dass wenn einer kaputt geht,
also mit kaputt gehen meine ich jetzt nicht einfach ausfallen oder so,
wenn da einer irgendwie zersplittert,
die Chance sehr hoch ist, dass die Trümmer den Nächsten treffen
und dann hast du zweimal Trümmer
und dann triffst du die nächsten 4 und die nächsten 8
und die nächsten 16 und die nächsten 32
und dass ganz viel kaputt geht
und dann hast du ganz, ganz viel Schrott oben rumkreisen
und kannst gar nicht mehr richtig ins Weltall fliegen.
...einfach mal ein Satellit tot ist
oder nicht mehr angesteuert werden kann
und dementsprechend nicht mehr ausweichen kann.
Dementsprechend bis zwei Objekte zusammenstoßen
und dadurch wiederum tausende Trümmerteile erzeugt werden,
die weitere Kollisionen auslösen.
Also eine Kettenreaktion,
die den gesamten Orbit unbrauchbar machen kann,
außer man räumt ihn wieder auf.
Da gibt es sogar Überlegungen zu mit dem Aufräumen. Von Einsammeln bis Lasern und sowas. Gibt schon Überlegungen zu.
dauert es 164 Tage, wenn niemand ausweicht.
Im Juni 2025 waren es noch 5,5 Tage, wenn niemand ausweicht.
Und im Januar 2026 waren es dann 3,8 Tage.
Forscher schätzen, ohne aktive Ausweichmanöver würde es statistisch alle 5,5 Tage zu einer Kollision kommen
und in Megakonstellationsregionen, also wo besonders viele Satelliten deployed sind, sogar noch häufiger.
Allerdings ganz kurz zu dem Paper, das ist nur ein Preprint und kein peer-reviewtes Paper, aber es zeigt durchaus einen Trend.
Starlink hat 2025 300.000 Ausweichmanöver durchgeführt.
820 am Tag, alle zwei Minuten weicht ein Satellit aus, so im Schnitt.
Und jetzt möchte man eine Million weitere reinstellen.
Also sowas in der Art von der Kreisverkehr ist arschvoll, ich packe nochmal 100.000 Autos rein.
Bei einer Million Satelliten mit 5 Jahren Lebensdauer würde alle 2,6 Minuten ein Satellit in unserer Atmosphäre verglühen.
Alle 2,6 Minuten, das ist, ihr könnt gerne mal gucken, wie lange das Video bis dahin gebraucht hat, wie viele das bis hierher wären.
Und das hinterlässt leider auch Spuren.
Forscher rechnen bei voller Ausbaustufe der Megakonstellation mit 360 Tonnen Aluminiumoxid pro Jahr in der Atmosphäre.
Fun Fact, Aluminiumoxid zerstört Ozon.
Und schon jetzt enthalten 10% der Partikel in der oberen Atmosphäre Metalle aus verglühten Satelliten.
Dazu kommt natürlich der Nachthimmel.
Die Royal Astronomical Society hat diese Woche, also am selben Tag wie NVIDIAs Ankündigung auf der GTC,
über die Pläne für eine Million Satelliten gesagt, sie würden den Nachthimmel merkbar zerstören und für immer vernarben.
Dennoch, es gibt keinen bindenden internationalen Vertrag.
Also niemand reguliert das am Ende.
Aber am Ende leiden alle darunter, wenn wir von dem Planeten hier nicht mehr runterkommen,
weil der Orbit vollgestopft ist mit Durchfahrtssperren aka Datenzentrumsmüll.
Die EU hat eine Studie finanziert, Ascent.
Diese Studie fragt, sind Rechenzentren im Weltraum vielleicht klimaneutral?
Die Ascent-Studie hat die Raketengase zum Hochschießen durchaus sogar mit eingerechnet.
Denn über 70% des gesamten CO2-Fußabdrucks kommen allein vom Launch.
Aber ihre Wirkung in der oberen Atmosphäre wurde leider ziemlich ignoriert.
Und den Rebound-Effekt, also dass billigerer Compute zu mehr Compute-Bedarf führt, wurde gleich mitignoriert.
Also klimaneutral, aber halt solange man ignoriert, was der Müll dort oben anrichten kann.
Deutschland hat übrigens sogar ein Gesetz dafür, also für Rechenzentren auf der Erde meine ich natürlich.
Das Energieeffizienzgesetz, das so verhasst ist, seit 2024.
Natürlich haben wir sowas.
Neue Rechenzentren mit über 300 Kilowatt müssen die Abwärme sogar nutzen.
Angefangen bei 10% bis Juli diesen Jahres, dann 15% bis 2027 und 20% bis 2028.
Das klingt hervorragend. Es gibt aber einen Haken.
Die maximale Strafe dabei sind 100.000 Euro.
Das juckt die halt mal absolut gar nicht.
Und es gibt sogar noch ein Schlupfloch mehr dazu.
Wenn der Wärmenetzbetreiber das Angebot des Rechenzentrumsbetreibers nicht innerhalb von 6 Monaten annimmt,
ist das Rechenzentrum befreit.
Das Gesetz verpflichtet also zur Lieferung, aber nicht zur Abnahme.
Die Lösung für das eigentliche Problem, also zu viel Hitze, wie uns das Marketing verkauft,
ist aber so unfassbar langweilig, dass sie nicht mal auf den Pitch deckt.
Nvidia hat auf der GTC Space One vorgestellt.
Deutschland hat ein Gesetz, das neue Rechenzentren zum Heizen verpflichtet,
mit einem Bußgeld, das Nvidia in der Kaffeepause verdient.
Wir reden hier über Kessler-Kaskaden und eine Million Satelliten.
Und auf der Erde schafft es die Politik halt nicht mal,
ein Heizungsrohr von einem Rechenzentrum in eine Wohnsiedlung zu verlegen.
Oder, noch viel besser, in einen Betonraum unter Genf.
Ich war tatsächlich da.
Ich stand in dem Rechenzentrum, Infomaniac in Genf.
Diesmal keine Werbung, Sie wissen nichts von dem Video, aber es ist halt wichtig, dass wir das wissen.
Das Ganze ist unterirdisch und beherbergt etwa 10.000 Server.
Nichts davon im Orbit.
Die Abwärme geht aber einfach ins Fernwärmenetz.
Bei Vollausbau heizen sie damit 6000 energieeffiziente Wohnungen.
100% der verbrauchten Energie geht einfach zurück in die Heizung.
3600 Tonnen CO2 werden so vermieden.
Und seit November 2024 ist das Ding in Betrieb.
Also, ich habe hier gerade über Weltraumrecht und Diffusion von Wärme im Orbit und was weiß ich was geredet.
Okay, also können wir sagen, Fazit?
Lösungs ist ein Wärmetauscher.
Manchmal ist Technologie...
Fazit ist wahrscheinlich keine so gute Idee.
Wahnsinnig langweilig und löst Probleme ohne neu zu erfinden, für die man sich danach wieder eine Lösung einkaufen muss.
Klar, wir können auch in 5 Jahren Elon Musk einfach als EU richtig viel Geld geben, damit er da oben wieder aufräumt.
Aber man könnte es auch einfach anders machen.
Also nochmal zurück zu Frankfurt.
Die Stadt, die ich am Anfang erwähnt habe.
Deutschlands Rechenzentrum Hauptstadt.
Kühlwasser aus dem Trinkwassernetz und...
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vitor Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Die Rechte stoppen die Neubauten.
Dieselbe Stadt könnte laut ECO-Verband rechnerisch bis 2030 ihre gesamten Wohn- und Büroflächen klimaneutral beheizen,
nur mit der Abwärme von Rechenzentren, die schon da sind.
Am Anfang des Videos waren also Rechenzentren...
Ja gut, in Frankfurt ist ja auch an jeder Ecke, wo du hinspuckst oder hinguckst, besser gesagt, steht ja irgendein Rechenzentrum.
... deren Hitze in Frankfurt ein Problem.
Jetzt plötzlich sind sie eine Lösung geworden.
Und ganz ehrlich, bei mir zu Hause mache ich das schon so.
Ist das etwa ein Mashify?
Ein Fractal Design Mashify?
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Rechenzentrum AK, dieses Monstrum hier unten heizt die ganze Wohnung und vor allem mein Arbeitszimmer.
Ich habe hier drin auch dieses Jahr genauso wenig geheizt wie die letzten fünf Jahre.
Und ich komme hier drin immer über 20K, egal wie kalt es draußen ist.
Wir brauchen also eigentlich keine Raketen, wir brauchen ein bisschen mehr politischen Willen.
Für mich ist das jetzt nicht eine Lektion von Rechenzentren im All sind verrückt,
die sind super clever, wenn man damit die Jurisdiktion aushebeln möchte.
Die Lektion ist eher, wir akzeptieren eine Welt, in der die Infrastruktur unserer digitalen Existenz
quasi physikalisch schon unerreichbar wird.
Ich kann nicht da hochfliegen und kein einziges Gericht kann irgendeinen Server beschlagnahmen.
Und kein einziger Forscher kann Code auditieren.
Naja, muss jeder für sich wissen.
Am Anfang dachte ich also wirklich, es ging um Kühlung, aber in Wahrheit ging es nicht wirklich um Kühlung.
Es ging darum, wer die Infrastruktur kontrolliert.
Also es geht im Prinzip darum, dass man machen kann, was man will.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe.
Und damit unser Leben bestimmt. Bis zum nächsten Mal im Cyberspace.
Ja.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Aber wenn wir irgendwann mal wirklich bei 20 Euro pro Kilogramm sind,
dann schicken wir ein paar
Platten mit Twitch-E-Mails
drauf ins Weltall.
Die können dann da oben rumkreisen
und keck-double-yuen.
Was steht da im Terminal?
Da steht
Afglo gleich wieder da.
Aber ich bin gar nicht mehr Afglo.
Kockers im Orbit.
Ja.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst?
Euer übertriebenen
Smart Homes. Ah ja, das gucke ich immer gerne.
Das gucke ich immer gerne.
Dann schauen wir uns das doch mal an
Eure übertriebenen Smart Homes
Was die da wieder gebastelt haben, die Leute
Die Sonne lacht
Es werden wieder Häuser und Gärten smart gemacht
Ne, mit sowas fangen wir hier gar nicht erst an
Auch wenn meine Reime natürlich Goethe und auch
ChatGBT vor Neid erblassen lassen
Aber wir schauen uns lieber an
was ihr bei euch smart gemacht habt
und ich habe auch eine Sache dabei
und dann inspirieren wir uns gegenseitig.
Gar nicht geschwafelt. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen rein.
Inspiriert mich.
Thomas sagt, nie wieder aufstehen
für Kaffee. Das geht übrigens ganz einfach,
wenn man, wie ich, keinen Kaffee trinkt.
Ich wollte gerade genau
das Gleiche sagen. Ich trinke einfach keinen Kaffee.
Aber ich könnte meinen Tee
nochmal leer trinken. Da ist immer viel drin.
Ja,
weil jetzt so viele Leute da sind. Ich habe es
am Anfang des Streams schon mal gesagt.
Grund, warum ich gestern nicht gestreamt habe, ist, weil ich vorgestern Abend kotzen musste.
Da habe ich mich gestern ein bisschen geschont.
Mir hat übelst der Magen wehgetan.
Wahrscheinlich zu viel Pizza gefressen, ich weiß es nicht.
Und um 20.30 Uhr oder so, musste ich dann zweimal richtig dick kotzen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich schone mich gestern mal und habe nicht gestreamt.
Kotzchamp
Ich hab seit 20 Jahren oder so
Musste ich nicht mehr kotzen
Also ich weiß nicht, woran es gelegen hat
Also muss ja
Ich mein, muss ja was
Muss ja was mit dem Essen zu tun haben
War die Pizza von dem Laden, der die schon mal krank gemacht hat?
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Die Pizza war selbst gemacht
Also, keine Ahnung
Vielleicht lag es auch am Quark oder so, den ich abends noch gegessen hab
Kann schon alles sein
Vielleicht hatte ich auch ein bisschen irgendwie so
Magenschleimhautreizung oder so, kann ja immer sein
Ach, guck mal hier, Classic
Classic Copypasta, die hab ich ja ewig nicht mehr gesehen
Egal, guck mal ins Video, weiter
Wer kennt das Problem nicht, man schaltet frühmorgens die Kaffeemaschine ein
Die Kaffeemaschine muss erstmal einen Spülvorgang machen
Dazu stellt man eine leere Tasse drunter
Muss die leere Tasse wegstellen, holt sich seine eigentliche Tasse
Stellt sie wieder unter die Kaffeemaschine
Kann die Kaffeezubereitung starten
Währenddessen steht man die ganze Zeit neben der Maschine
und ein Haufen Zeit verloren.
Ich war gestern schon wieder fit.
Ich werde jetzt noch ein bisschen
weniger fettreiches Futter
in den nächsten zwei, drei Tagen und dann
ist, denke ich, wieder alles okay.
Um diese ganze Sache jetzt smarter
und vor allen Dingen automatisiert zu machen, habe ich im ersten
Schritt jetzt erstmal angefangen, die Kaffeemaschine
zu zerlegen, um mir das Innere der Maschine
anzuschauen. Die ganzen Taster
an der Front der Maschine,
die normalerweise über das
Drücken betätigt werden. Diese
Taster habe ich jeweils zwei
Kabel angelötet und diese Kabel
habe ich durch die Maschine
seitlich abgeführt. Ganz ehrlich?
Ach ne, vergiss es,
vergiss es. Ich wollte sagen,
ich bin ja auch Bastler und wir haben ja auch
schon viele Sachen gelötet und gebastelt im
Stream, aber an 230 Volt
bastel ich nicht gerne rum.
Aber ist es anscheinend auch gar nicht, oder?
Die Kabel gehen dann auf zwei Relais.
Die Relais werden wiederum von dem ESP angesteuert
und können entsprechend dann die Taster brücken.
Home Assistant kann jetzt HTTP-Befehle an den ESP senden
und somit kann Home Assistant die Kaffeemaschine einschalten
oder die Kaffeezubereitung starten.
Jetzt war schon mal das Problem mit dem Knöpfe drücken gelöst.
Und jetzt noch das Problem mit dem Spielvorgang
und den beiden Tassen zu lösen,
habe ich mich an Fusion 360 gesetzt
und habe einen passenden Rahmen für die Tropfschneide konstruiert.
An dem Rahmen ist ein kleiner Schrittmotor befestigt,
Das ist aber advanceder Shit, Alter.
...über eine Kupplung mit einer M8-Gewindestange verbunden ist.
Der Motor kann die Gewindestange drehen und somit den Tisch oben nach links und rechts fahren.
Auch dieser Motor ist über einen UEM-Freiwarn mit dem ESP verbunden.
Somit kann jetzt Home Assistant über den ESP...
Das ist richtig, hat auch verengineert. Das finde ich geil.
...über dem Motor nach links und rechts fahren.
Im ersten Schritt wird die Kaffeemaschine eingeschaltet.
Anschließend vorgehend 40 Sekunden.
In dieser Zeit kann die Kaffeemaschine hochfahren und den Spülvorgang durchführen.
So und in Aktion sieht das Ganze wie folgt aus.
Zugegebenermaßen durch den kleinen 5 Volt Schrittmotor bewegen sich die Tassen relativ langsam.
Für meine Zwecke ist das aber vollkommen ausreichend.
Und es schwappt nichts raus. Du musst es einfach als Vorteil verkaufen.
Sowieso, wenn die Automation gestartet wird, frühmorgens im Bad bzw. in der Dusche.
Da ich jetzt natürlich frühmorgens zu faul bin, die Automation manuell zu starten,
habe ich, wie es sich in einem guten Smart Home gehört, meine Bewegungsmärter dafür verwendet,
die Automation frühmorgens automatisch zu starten.
Dazu habe ich einfach einen bestimmten Zeitslot festgelegt von 30 Minuten.
Werden in diesen 30 Minuten die Bewegungsmärter im Flur und im Bad ausgelöst, wird die Automation gestartet.
Okay, hatten wir ja von einiger Zeit schon mal ähnlich.
Da gab es dieses Rondell, das die Kaffeetassen rein rotiert hat.
Das hier ist natürlich sehr viel platzspannender.
Du bist fairerweise auch da ganz schön rein eskaliert.
Ja, und nur eine Tasse.
Aber das ist geil. Das ist wirklich abgedreht.
Aber sehr cool für jemanden, der Kaffee trinkt.
Was mir tatsächlich einfach nicht in den Kopf fällt, dass die ganzen Vollautomaten überhaupt keine Vollautomaten sind.
Weil dann müssten sie ja selber das Spülen irgendwie automatisch abhandeln.
Entweder da selber irgendwas unterstellen oder eine größere Tropfschale haben oder so.
Weil sämtliche Fernsteuerung ergibt ja nur dann Sinn, wenn das Spülen irgendwie auch von der Maschine selbst übernommen wird.
Da möchte ich von den Maschinenherstellern mehr sehen. Das kann doch nicht sein, dass ihr das alle selber machen müsst.
So ist es.
Die ursprüngliche Idee war eigentlich, die Temperatur des Pools via Siri abzufragen.
Ich habe mir dazu einen kleinen Sensor bestellt, den ich hier am Pool montiert habe.
Der läuft über SIGBI und geht dann via Kabel zur Poolleiter ungefähr in die Mitte des Pools hinein.
Dann hatte ich im Frühjahr das Problem, dass mir das Wasser immer wieder trüb geworden ist.
und festgestellt, dass aufgrund der Wärmepumpe das Wasser auf 30 Grad erhitzt worden ist
und dass ich da die Poollaufzeit deutlich verlängern musste.
Von den sechs Stunden, die ich dachte, auf 15 Stunden.
Das ist das Kühlfiltern beim Whisky nur rückwärts.
Du hast dann Schwebstoff...
Hey Siri!
Moment, der Pool ist trüb geworden, weil er zu warm war oder wie?
Oder was?
Oder wie?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt.
Wie ist die Temperatur im Pool?
Es hat 31 Grad Celsius im Pool.
31 Grad im Pool?
Das ist bestimmt eine angenehme Temperatur, oder?
Diese Information...
Ich habe doch keinen plassen Schimmer von.
Was ist eine angenehme Wassertemperatur?
Da kann ich dann entscheiden, wie lange die Poolpumpe laufen soll.
Also zum Beispiel unter 24 Grad.
Also meine Körpertemperatur ist um die 37 Grad.
Also ist wahrscheinlich angenehmes Wasser.
Auch 37 Grad?
Kein Schimmer.
Grad, also 6 Stunden laufen, beziehungsweise über 30 Grad dann 15 Stunden.
Ich bekomme dann noch eine Benachrichtigung und zack, um circa 20 Uhr, wie lange die
Poolpumpe gelaufen ist, das funktioniert prächtig. So ein Pool ist ja schon Arbeit, was?
Also aufpassen, dass das Wasser nicht kippt, Temperaturmanagement und 15 Stunden
eine Pumpe laufen lassen, das ist natürlich auch ein Stromverbrauch. Und im Zweifelsfall
kannst du aber ja natürlich auch, wenn das so warm wird, die Wärmepumpe rückwärts
laufen lassen, oder? Das können doch diese Pool-Wärmepumpen.
Dann verbrauchst du natürlich noch mehr Strom.
Aber gut, wenn das Wasser
30 Grad hat, dann sollte
ja auch genügend PV-Strom da
sein, um das Ganze
zu egalisieren.
Also ich meine, bei zu warmer Außentemperatur
willst du auch nicht in so einen pi-warmen Pool springen,
oder? Ich meine, was weiß ich schon, aber
30 Grad ist ja, das wäre mir, glaube ich,
zu warm zum Abkühlen.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht einschätzen.
wie warm das sich anfühlt.
Ja, mich auch nicht.
Ich hab so einen Fake-Pool,
der kein richtiger Pool ist.
Ich hab einen Fischteich
im Garten,
der wurde vom Opa
aber ursprünglich als Pool
gebaut. Da sind halt auch so,
also wenn das sauber
geputzt ist, der Fischteich,
dann ist es so blau unten. Es ist halt so ausgelegt,
wie bei einem Pool.
Da hat er sich was bei gedacht. Also generell hat der Opa hier viele coole Sachen gebaut. Aber das kannst du natürlich vergessen. Da ist keine Pumpe dran und das ist ein Teich im Endeffekt. Aber er hat den mal als Pool gebaut.
... natürlich Poolroboter testen könnte und solche Automationen bauen.
Wenn ihr Automationen gebaut habt, die ich mir anschauen sollte,
dann werft sie gerne unter zeug.coolslash zeigen über den Zaun
und jede hier im Video verwurstete Einsendung wird mit einem 50 Euro Amazon-Gutschein belohnt.
Also ran an den Lachs.
Und damit das alles möglich ist, hilft uns der heutige Partner,
die Delta 3 Max Plus von EcoFlow.
Es ist ja immer sinnvoll...
Ich skippe mal kurz.
... dann hilft die Dämpfer zu 1000 Watt Spitzen.
Ganz einfach den Batteriemanagement wieder auf Minuten voll.
Und dabei Modul und notwendig in den Blick.
Den Max-Gebote für die Stream-Balkon-Kraftwerke wurde mit meinem Code.
Hier um meines Netzwerkschranks, damit ich auf jeden Fall in letzter Zeit viel
U mit KNX und DALI-Beleuchtung gemeinsam steuern hier rum experimentiert.
Aber das ganz Frische ist auf jeden Fall diese kleine Geschichte.
Wir haben ja oben diese roten Dachfenster, die motorisiert sind.
Weiß das kann tatsächlich sein?
Weiß ich nicht.
So ein Pool im Garten haben wäre schon irgendwie nice.
Aber das ist halt auch schweineteuer.
Platz wäre ja sogar da.
Ich meine jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt für einen 50 Meter oder so.
Aber so 10 Meter oder so vielleicht.
Das ist aber halt teuer als Fakt.
Das bin ich zu geizig für.
Dafür kannst du dir enorm viele nass kaufen.
Was kostet es, einen Pool zu bauen zu lassen?
Der Bau eines Pools kostet je nach Art und Größe
zwischen 1000 Euro und 30.000
Na geil
Swimmingpoolrechner.de
Sowas ist bestimmt
teuer as fuck, Alter
Schnapper.
Was Gartenbewässerung ohne Festwasseranschluss.
Mit lokaler Steuerung ohne Wasseranschluss.
Dazu nutze ich diese kleine Gardena Taufpumpe, die es sowohl als Set als auch einzeln mit und ohne Netzteil zu kaufen gibt.
Man kann sie mit bis zu drei Rohren des 4,6 mm Systems verbinden, um damit beliebige Kombinationen von Micro-Drip-Tropfern und Düsen zu nutzen.
Das mitgelieferte Netzteil hat mehrere Zeitschaltungen und eine Einstellung, bei der es für drei Minuten, nachdem es Strom bekommt, wässert und dann stoppt.
Diese Funktion mache ich mir zu nutzend, habe sie an eine geschaltete Steckdose gehängt, die über Home Assistant bedarfsgerecht riftsteuert wird.
Als Reservoir dient diese aufgrund lichtundurchlässige Box von Ikea, die ca. 55 Liter fasst.
Da ist es dunkel genug, dass nichts drin wächst, außer der Kalk, der hierzulande offensichtlich schon beim leichten Anwärmen auf Umgebungstemperatur ausfällt.
Für die bedarfsgerechte Steuerung nutze ich die Bodenfeuchte, die ich mit diesen Sensoren der Firma Ecovit messe, die ich über das Gateway in Home Assistant integriert habe.
Ja, so Dinge habe ich auch mal gehabt für die Terrasse.
Das sind aber nicht diese Dinge.
Ich hatte von Xiaomi, glaube ich, welche...
Die waren Schrott. Die haben auch nicht lange gehalten.
Vielleicht sind die besser.
In Home Assistant gibt es dazu eine mitgelieferte Integration
und das Gateway pusht die Daten lokal direkt zum Home Assistant.
Es gibt mehrere Gateways von Ecovit, manche können nur WiFi.
Die meisten können aber mehrere Wettersensoren und bis zu 16 Bodenfeuchte-Sensoren verarbeiten.
Nur keine Umlaut.
Die Sensoren kosten je nach Internetwetter ca. 20-25€ auf Amazon und sind auch gerne
Geht sogar klar.
Mal im Prime Day Angebot dabei.
Sie werden mit einer AA-Batterie betrieben, die bei mir schon über zwei Jahre hält.
Das ist gut.
In Home Assistant habe ich mir ein kleines Dashboard zur Überwachung gebaut.
Oben links.
53% Bambus und zwei Wasser.
Hier sieht man die aktuelle Feuchte und den Füllstand des Reservoirs.
Dieser ist über einen einfachen Zähler realisiert, den ich immer zurücksetze, wenn ich das Wasser nachgefüllt habe.
Der Zähler wird dann verringert, wenn die Steckdose für mehr als drei Minuten oder beim Starten der Home Assistant Instanz an war.
Gleichzeitig wird die Steckdose auch wieder deaktiviert, um sie für den nächsten Einsatz vorzubereiten.
Darunter sieht man den Sollwert, über dem keine Bewässerung stattfindet.
Ist es morgens oder abends, habe ich überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck für sowas, aber sicherlich coole Lösung, wenn man denn sowas gärtnert.
Der Wert der Bodenfeuchte unter diesem Sollwert wird gewässert.
Hier sind beliebige Automationen auch in Kombination mit der Wetterfrequenz.
Weißt du, was ich mich da gerade frage?
Mein Opa ist früher immer noch mit dem Schlauch durch den Garten gelaufen und hat die Pflanzen gegossen.
Ich wohne jetzt hier seit über zehn Jahren.
Ich war nicht einmal im Garten.
Ich habe nicht einmal Pflanzen gegossen.
Und da wächst immer noch massig Zeug im Garten.
Kann man sich fragen, vielleicht muss das gar nicht sein.
Oder aber, das was anfällig ist, ist schon alles kaputt und jetzt wächst nur noch Unkraut.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Oder anderen Parametern denkbar.
Auf jeden Fall ganz spannend.
Also gerade weil diese bodenfeuchte Sensoren, da gibt es ja sehr viele sehr einfache, die dann auch nicht lange halten.
Und wenn du sagst, deiner hält mit einem Satz Batterien schon zwei Jahre, dann hält der ja schon mal zwei Jahre.
Insgesamt finde ich schon ganz spannend und schön, dass das alles auch lokal läuft.
Und bei bis zu zweimal täglich Wässern sollten die Pflanzen im Sommer ja abgehen wie Schmidts Katze.
Das ist dann auch direkt das Tier in der heutigen Automation.
Falls wir keine anderen mehr sehen, würde ich sagen.
Wir sehen hier schon einen Taster und einen Wasserhahn.
Und wir gehen mal rein in die Wasserzentrale.
Das sind insgesamt neun IBC-Tanks.
Da stehen nochmal drei und hinten eine ordentliche Menge.
Und auch nochmal.
Okay.
Und hier sehen wir schon die Pumpstation.
verteiler wasseruhr die per impulsgeber angeschlossen ist und zu sehen wie viel
wasser durchgeht hier haben wir wollte ich auch mal machen nicht an knx
anschließen die den zähler auslesen also von vom vom wasser unten
wobei mein zähler hat hat kein kein keine led oder sowas sondern hat irgendwie
so das ist irgendwie so magnetisch oder so habe ich gelesen da musste irgendwie
so kontakt dran hängen und da ist ein magnet drin und das zählt irgendwie oder
habe ich habe ich nur mal überlegt habe ich dann nie gemacht
warum geht das an die wenn das andere kann es gesteuert wird also warum machst
du nicht alles mit knx gut vielleicht hast du einfach keinen schaltbaren
kontakt mehr frei fähig ein tapu zwischenstecker aber bis jetzt schlägt
das ich ganz gut sonst gehört noch dazu ein level sensor
Dein Stromzähler ist von 1984.
Dann hast du bestimmt noch so ein Ding.
Oder?
Hast du noch so ein Ding?
Ja.
Da kann man aber eigentlich keine Magnete...
Also man darf da eigentlich keine Magnete dran machen.
Weil Magnete sorgen dafür, dass der Zähler nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was man machen kann, ist sowas hier, was diese Verfärbung erkennt und weitergibt.
Aber sowas habe ich mir mal gebaut, haben wir glaube ich sogar im Stream ausprobiert.
Das hat nie so richtig zuverlässig funktioniert.
das ist ein
kopf in der rossby und unten drin ist jetzt aber alles da hat sein zeug per knx dran ein
shelly und jetzt haben wir das bei am start der guckt wieder wie voll der tank ist auf
den tank für stand ist ja und dafür stand wird dann auch alle tages hochgerechnet da würde ich
aber kein raspberry pi dran machen da brauchst du kein vollständiges linux was wir die preis sind
auch oftmals wenn die so ein bisschen hier im außenbereich sind sind ein bisschen fehler
anfällig und die sd karten machen auch manchmal schlapp also da wir irgend so ein sp 32 oder so
was bestimmt die robustere variante verbunden und die dritte ist auch per knx angeschlossen drücke
dann öffnet sich zuerst das ventil man auch für die kumpel angehen
wir schicken eine notification wird auch gewässert das tropft also du weißt dass
dass die pumpe jetzt für sechs stunden läuft.
das heißt ich pump wasser, die pumpe pumpt.
für sechs stunden?
und wenn wir wieder tasten geht erst die pumpe aus und nach ein paar sekunden wird das magnetventil zufallen.
auch ganz spannend.
ich hab's ehrlich gesagt absolut nicht gecheckt wofür das da ist. habt ihr das kapiert?
gerade noch irgendwie.
das war mir zu high iq das ding.
ist das getränkter zulauf? nee das ist der zulauf überhaupt vom dach ne und dann wird das so verteilt.
Zum Wasser auf die Straße laufen lassen?
Was?
Aber dann, ach ne, hier sind die verbunden.
Na, okay.
Oder kannst du es darüber auch extern zufüllen?
Also, wir haben ja jetzt auch die Hälfte des Hausdachs an der Zisterne angeschlossen.
Und das erhöht sich bald hoffentlich auf drei Viertel.
Und dann müssen wir mal sehen, dass das Wasser auch sinnvoll verteilt wird, was da drin zusammenkommt.
Aber es wäre auch wichtig, dass es dann aufgefüllt wird, sollte die Zisterne mal leer laufen.
weil wir keine 9000 Liter Tanks im Garten verteilt bekommen.
Aber bei mir muss jetzt auf jeden Fall auch die automatische Bewässerung kommen.
Also mindestens für das Gewächshaus und für die ersten Beete.
Insgesamt haben wir für den Garten auch die automatische Bewässerung kommen.
Das sieht aus, als will er sich da noch Hühner halten oder sowas.
Insgesamt haben wir für den Garten dieses Jahr einiges vor.
Abonniert gerne, wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollt.
Übrigens, so ein geschlossenes Häuschen für Hühner für nachts ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, weil mein Nachbar hatte jetzt schon mehrfach Hühner und die haben es alle nicht lange überlebt.
Der hat dann immer so vier, fünf Hühner und alle paar Jahre sind die, nach und nach werden die gefressen.
So fast, was weiß ich, Marder und Greifvögel oder keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Und zumindest verschwinden die immer und nach ein paar Wochen sind die dann alle weg.
Und dann irgendwie ein halbes Jahr, dreiviertel Jahr später holt er sich einfach wieder neun Satzhühner.
er meint halt, es ist billiger,
sich einfach immer neuen Satz Hühner zu holen,
als das irgendwie einbruchsicher gegen
Fressfresser, Fressfeinde,
nee, wie nennt man das?
Beutefresser,
Raubtiere, könnte man sagen. Ich glaube, Raubtiere
wäre das korrekte Wort.
Und
das ist billiger.
Das heißt, der hat jetzt schon wieder,
glaube ich, ein Jahr oder so neue Hühner. Wahrscheinlich
wird bald wieder das erste gefressen.
Max geht vorbei und snackt sich eins.
Also die Katz von mir, die noch in den Garten gegangen ist,
die hat immer super auf wichtig getan vor den Hühnern.
Die ist immer an den Zaun, wo die Hühner waren.
Also hinter dem Zaun waren die Hühner.
Und hat sich dann immer vor den Zaun gestellt.
Und hat sich ganz groß gemacht und wichtig und rumposiert.
Um den Hühnern zu zeigen, wer hier der Chef ist.
Die maximale Regenwassernutzung und Speicherung ist natürlich sehr smart,
weil es am besten für den Garten und für die Brieftasche und die Natur ist.
David hat smarte Mülltonnen und die kamen ja beim letzten Mal schon gut an.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal, ob seine totale Mülltonnenüberwachung bei euch genauso gut ankommt.
Das andere Video findet ihr übrigens hier.
Ich habe meine...
Ich hatte schon geguckt.
Das haben wir glaube ich auch nicht.
Können wir das nächste Mal gucken.
Mülltonnen smart gemacht.
Hier ist das so, hier wohnen mehrere Parteien in einem Haus,
die alle die Mülltonnen rausstellen könnten.
Früher gab es eine einfache Automation,
die das bei uns im Haus eingesagt hat, in der Wohnung.
Und das hat manchmal funktioniert, manchmal nicht.
Deswegen habe ich das angesagt hat.
Ich habe eingesagt verstanden.
Aber was wurde da, wer wurde in Sark angesagt?
Ich habe jetzt hier für alle ersichtlich eine Anzeige gemacht, die zeigt, welche Mülltonnen...
Diese Mülltonnen werden morgen geleert.
Und dann...
Ach so!
Ja, sowas habe ich auch.
Sowas habe ich auch.
Bei uns ist aber keine Anzeige an den Mülltonnen.
Wobei ich das auch sehr cool finde.
Bei uns ist es halt auf den Tablets.
Hier hängt ja im ersten Stock und im Erdgeschoss hängt halt ein Tablet an der Wand mit Home Assistant Dashboard und so drauf.
Und da gibt es eine Anzeige, welche Tonnen die nächsten Tage geleert werden.
Wobei ich die Anzeige an den Tonnen selber echt nice finde.
Das einzige Problem, was ich mir da gerade vorstelle ist,
wie versorge ich den
ESP
für diese Anzeige
mit Strom
mit Batterien ist natürlich blöd
bei dauerhafter LED, das ist relativ schnell leer
Solar ist auch nicht so geil
muss man irgendwie Strom hinlegen
dann fährt es schon wieder blöd
PoE, wie soll ich ein Netzwerkkabel
da hinkriegen
Am nächsten Tag rausgestellt werden.
Habt ihr eine...
Also, was ist denn das?
Habt ihr eine eigene Tonne für Räder?
Oder ist es eine für Orang-...
Das ist eine gute Frage, was das ist.
Also, okay.
Das ist die gelbe Tonne.
Gelbe Tonne.
Hier würde ich sagen, alles Müll.
Was ist das hier?
Biotonne? Oder was soll das sein?
Räder.
Verstehe ich nicht, was das sein soll.
Das ist Papier, oder? Das ist Papier. Da kann ja das hier eigentlich nur die Biotonne sein. Wobei ich den Zusammenhang zwischen LED, äh, zwischen, nicht LED, zwischen dem Icon und Bio. Ach, ist das hier eine Zitrone oder sowas? Ne, was, also, das ist eine Banane und eine Zitrone.
Oh, da muss man aber schon
Next Level sein
Wisst ihr, was ich da besser finde?
Einfach die Tonnenfarbe drunter
Ja, also ich hab das
Bei uns im Dashboard so gemacht
Die Tonnenfarbe wird einfach angezeigt
Blaue Tonne, gelbe Tonne
Stimmt, sieht aus wie ein Fallschirm, ja
Fallschirm mit nem Rad dran
keine Dauer-LED nehmen, sondern
irgendeine Klappanzeige dran machen.
Chat, ich habe noch eine bessere Idee.
Ein
E-Ink-Display.
Ein E-Ink-Display
mit einem ESP32
in ein wasserdichtes Gehäuse.
Das könnte
durchaus
funktionieren für eine ganze Weile
mit einem Akku draußen.
und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und und
Wahrscheinlich der Deckel auf sein, ja.
Ja, genau, sowas in der Richtung hier.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Die Herausforderung bei solchen Outdoor-Dingern ist nur, also ist nicht nur, aber ist auch hauptsächlich, sie wasserdicht zu bekommen.
Das heißt, da bräuchte man sowas hier zum Beispiel, Verteilerdose, sowas hier bräuchte man dann zum Beispiel, sowas da und dann müsste man sich überlegen, wie bekommt man da jetzt irgendwie ein Fenster rein für das E-Ink Display.
und man kann ja da nicht einfach ein Loch
reinschneiden, weil dann ist es ja nicht
mehr wasserdicht.
Man müsste dort irgendeine
Folie oder irgendwie
sowas oder ein Glas
und dann dran kleben
oder ah, das ist in der Tat
nicht so einfach, ja.
Ja, rausschneiden,
ein bisschen Plexiglas
oder sowas.
Da gibt es
mit Sichtfenster.
Gibt es sowas?
Nach was soll ich
googeln?
Dose, Dose, Dose.
Sichtfenster.
Ne, das ist
Metall. Das ist schon mal schlecht.
Ich brauche
irgendwas aus Plastik.
Wenn ich hier
ein teiler dose transparent
ja schon besser
aber auch deutlich teurer am liebsten wäre mir ja was wo man wirklich nur das
display sehen würde
Aber sowas wäre auch schon mal ganz okay.
Aber 10 Euro für ein Stück Preise.
Ja, also da muss man sich das passende dafür suchen.
Ja, dann könnte man hier das E-Ink Display dahinter machen.
Am besten würdest du halt was finden, wo das E-Ink Display nahezu den gesamten Space hier vorne ausfüllt.
Aber das sind so harte Plastikdinger.
Da ist es wieder schwierig einen Sensor durchzubekommen.
Wobei das auch geht.
Es gibt ja so Stufenbohrer.
Damit kann man da schöne Löcher reinmachen.
Dann braucht man so ein Durchführungsding.
Aber schon mal gute Idee.
Ich meine, das ist in der Tat, das finde ich, das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
E-Ink Display für Mülltonnen mit Akku.
Das muss ich auf jeden Fall mit einem
ESP32 Fire Beetle oder sowas
machen. Irgendwas, was sehr, sehr sparsam ist.
Dass das mit einem Akku
auch mal 1-2 Jahre hält.
Akkuanzeige
aufs Display auch noch.
Kauf die Sachen bei Ali.
Wenn ich die Sachen bei AliExpress kaufe, dann
dauert es ja ewig.
Gibt es eigentlich
Moment, E-Ink-Display
Wasserdicht
Gibt es sowas schon fertig
What the
Na ganz so teuer sollte es dann vielleicht doch nicht werden
Das ist wasserdicht, das glaube ich nicht.
Eats Delivery.
Das ist nicht wasserdicht.
Wie kommen die da drauf bei der Anzeige?
aber das ist eine coole idee
so wo waren das video jetzt wo sie mal stehen geblieben
Ja.
So, hier oben habe ich die Möglichkeit,
alle Tonnen anzuzeigen,
anzeigen zu lassen in verschiedenen Farben.
So, morgen werden Zitronenscheiben abgeholt.
Die am nächsten Tag geleert werden.
Grün, das ist Limette.
Und das ist natürlich alles über
Home Assistant hinterlegt.
Home Assistant!
So, aktuell stehen alle Mülltonnen am Platz.
Ich habe Hunger, Leute. Nach dem Video gehe ich essen.
Dann sollte der Ultraschallsensor merken,
ist der Abstand. Nachdem ich gestern
nicht gestreamt habe, komme ich vielleicht schon mit da nochmal on.
Größer wird und markiert die Mülltonne
so als abwesend. Ich muss nicht bei AliExpress
kaufen, bevor es teurer wird. Ich muss
einfach bei AliExpress über 150
Euro bestellen. Easy, dann umgehe
ich die teureren Gebühren.
Ich bestelle einfach mehr
zusammen als viel
Einzel. Ne, nicht Ludl
mit Lachs. Wie gesagt, ich musste vor zwei Tagen
kotzen abends.
Ich werde heute wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen die Suppe von
gestern futtern mit Toastbrot dabei.
Wenn er wieder reingeschoben wird, dauert das ein paar Sekunden und dann sollte die Mülltonne wieder da sein.
Dann habe ich einfach eine ziemlich einfache Automation in Home Assistant gebaut.
Home Assistant?
Die Trigger sind Uhrzeiten 17.
Hast du das mit unter die Dusche genommen?
19.20 Uhr, weil ja um 16 Uhr schon das erste Mal eine andere Automation getriggert wurde, um mich daran zu erinnern.
die überprüft jetzt, ob die Anzahl der anwesenden Mülltonnen größer ist als 4 minus die Anzahl der rausgestellten, weil 4 Tonnen inzwischen da ist.
Das würde bedeuten, dass noch nicht genügend Tonnen rausgestellt werden.
Habt ihr gesehen, Home Assistant hat jetzt irgendwie auch so einen grafischen Automation Designer oder sowas als Beta.
Meine Home Assistant Version ist noch ein bisschen älter, den habe ich noch nicht.
Und wenn das so ist, dann wird auf einem Sonos ein Kommando wiedergegeben, dass bitte die Tonnen rausgestellt werden sollen.
Eine Außensirene fehlt für alle Nachbarn.
Wenn euch interessiert, wie ich an die Daten gekommen bin, ich habe hier in Home Assistant Help verfügig eine Mülltonne erstellt, die mit einem Template überprüfen, die nehmen den Abstand von dem Ultraschallsensor, gucken, ob der kleiner ist als 71 cm und wenn das so ist, dann ist die Mülltonne unwesend und wird also die binäre Barriere auch angesetzt. Das habe ich für alle vier Mülltonnen gemacht.
Was ich da machen würde, was ich da auf jeden Fall noch machen würde, ich würde nicht einfach nur kleine 71% checken, ich würde checken, ist quasi, also ich würde das irgendwie so debouncen noch, ja, also, dass wenn es einmal falsch misst, das nicht gleich heißt, die Tonne muss raus, so nach dem Motto, wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Also dass man quasi sagt, okay, das muss über die letzten fünf Minuten zu 99% über dem Abstand liegen und sowas in der Richtung. Das muss man bei solchen Messgeräten immer mit einkalkulieren, dass die Dinger auch mal eins von tausend Mal oder so auch mal Mist melden.
Die Bouncen ist das falsche Wort, die Bouncen ist ja bei Knöpfen, bei Buttons.
Das habe ich für alle vier Mülltonnen gemacht.
An dieser Stelle noch kurz der Hinweis, dass ich im Schnitt wahrscheinlich manche von den Einsendungen ein bisschen kürzen werde, damit das hier irgendwie schön straff rüberkommt.
Ihr findet die originale Einsendung, wo dann oft auch noch ein bisschen mehr Erklärung bei ist, unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wenn euch was interessiert, schaut da gern vorbei.
An dieser Stelle gerade für Home Assistant und Müll nochmal der Hinweis auf das Plugin Waste Collection Schedule.
Das für sehr viele Kommunen und Kommunen.
so die Müllkalender
automatisch abrufen kann und dann im Home System
Kalender darstellen, aber auch
passende Sensoren einfach
anbieten kann. Damit habe ich
unsere...
Bei mir sieht es fast genauso aus
wie bei ihm.
Fast genauso.
Nur, dass bei mir nur die Tonnenfarben sind
und nicht irgendwelche komischen Icons.
Aber so finde ich das auch nicht schlecht.
Bei mir sieht es fast mehr oder weniger genauso aus.
Mülltonnendarstellung
in meinem kleinen Dashboard gebastelt.
Ist mittlerweile ganz nett geworden, weil vieles jetzt per Interface zu lösen ist und nicht mehr wilde Konfigurationsdateien schreiben.
So, bei Tobias bin ich ein bisschen skeptisch.
Der hat sich offenbar eine Automation gebaut, die ihn unzufrieden duschen lässt.
Mein Heizungs-Warmwasser-Wohnungsstationssystem ist ein wenig schwach ausgelegt,
was dazu führt, dass das Warmwasser beim Duschen bisweilen nur laumwarm ist.
Insbesondere, wenn gleichzeitig die Fußbodenheizung Wärme abzieht.
Kaltes Duschwasser führt zu Unzufriedenheit der Freundin, da muss man also was tun.
Ich habe da mal testweise die Wasserpumpe der Fußbodenheizung deaktiviert beim Duschen und siehe da, das Warmwasser beim Duschen ist bei mir spürbar wärmer, wenn die Fußbodenheizung nicht Wärme abzieht.
Also fix einen Duschtaster gebastelt. Bei Druck wird die Wasserpumpe für 30 Minuten deaktiviert, was der Duschwassertemperatur hilft.
Gleichzeitig kommandiere ich die Lüftungsanlage bei Duschtastendruck hoch und ich hoffe mir auch
an einen psychosomatischen Effekt bei der Nutzerin, denn wenn man selber aktiv am Taster und so macht,
dann muss das ja was helfen. Umgesetzt ist das Ganze in Home Assistant. Der Schalter wird über
einen Jelly eingelesen und die Wasserpumpe über die Fritz Schaltsteckdose geschaltet. Ist eh praktisch,
weil man dann im Sommer einen Festsetzschutz der Pumpe, also gelegentlich kurz anschalten,
dazu bauen kann. Einfach aber hilfreich, vielleicht für euch relevant. Servus, ciao!
Ich hoffe für dich, dass das gemietet ist. Ich meine, wir hatten auch viel unzureichendes
Handwerk im Haus, aber bei zu kalter Dusche hört der Spaß dann irgendwann auf. Ich meine,
das ist nicht mal kalt duschen, das ist ja noch viel schlimmer. Das ist wie abgestandenes
Sprudelwasser. Das ist schlimmer als Leitungswasser. Ich meine, also deine Automation ist gut,
aber ich will damit sagen dafür müssen köpfe rollen und wir sind gleich wieder im badezimmer
bei lukas schauen wir mal das automatische badezimmer fenster ich möchte euch heute
kurz unsere badezimmer automatisierung zeigen und zwar haben wir hier ein fenster das man
immer öffnen sollte wenn man duscht deswegen gibt es hier oben einen luftfreundlichkeitssensor also
das ist was wo ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie darüber nachgedacht habe das zu automatisieren ja wenn ich
aus der Dusche komme, dann
mache ich einfach
das Fenster im Bad auf.
Das kann man entweder kippen oder
komplett aufmachen. Ich mache es
meistens komplett auf.
Und 10 Minuten später mache ich das
wieder zu.
Was ich natürlich noch machen könnte, ist ein
10 Minuten Reminder oder sowas.
Aber das Fenster
automatisch öffnen,
das stelle ich mir auch enorm kompliziert
vor, weil das ist noch so ein Oldschool
fenster mit so einem begriff den man drehen muss die luftfertigkeit über 90
prozent ist und dann das fenster automatisch öffnet wenn sie wieder um
60 prozent fällt wird das fenster auch wieder automatisch geschlossen
wir haben hier eine leere aca mit zwei angepassten anschlägen ein paar
akkulplatten und ein paar montage punkte am fenster dann haben wir hier eine
kleine box mit einem sp32 und die sph einem netzteil und zwei relais die den
motor ein und ausschalten können wenn das ganze überschreiben will gibt es
hier auch diesen ikea city switch mit dem wir hier manuell das fenster öffnen
und schließen können und damit ich nicht lange über heißen brei redet möchte ich
euch einfach gleich aber wenn der griff da nicht zu gemacht wird kann man das
fenster doch easy von außen aufmachen oder und darüber einsteigen die dusche aufdrehen
ja noch nicht sicher hierbei es sieht schon ein bisschen abenteuerlich aus aber jetzt
funktioniert bei der verwurstung des ganzen das sieht noch ein bisschen provisorisch aus aber
ja mit automatisch öffnen und schließen den fenstern hast du mich einfach ich bin der
dass wir in einer zeit leben in der sich eigentlich inzwischen alle fenster automatisch öffnen und
schließen sollten also vielleicht muss man mit dieser geschichte im erdgeschoss ein bisschen
aufpassen aber ja gut noch mal kurz die erinnerung wenn ihr selber irgendwelche automationen bei euch
gebaut habt die hier gerne zeigen wollt dann werft sie gern bei zeug von kurs die eigenswert
haltungsvideo für die kanalmitglieder die meine arbeit noch eine habe ich nämlich von luca noch
eins bekommen ich zeig dir heute mal mein mobile sport und zwar ist das ganze nach räumen aufgeteilt
verlinken seite befindet sich immer die lichtsteuerung mit allen szenen des raums
gut der sport im kurs in die schätze das ist immer super individuell ist es logisch muss
gestehen ich kenne lukas der sport schon beziehungsweise bekam ich schon das ist
immer sehr individuell wie man der sports nächstes mal gucken wir uns ich gucke diese
Videos echt gerne. Nächstes Mal können wir...
Vor einem Jahr. Vielleicht haben wir das schon geguckt,
das letzte Mal.
Katzen automatisch füttern.
Ehe recht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Egal. Gucken wir das nächste Mal.
Vielleicht haben wir schon geguckt. Dann gucken wir es das nächste Mal nicht.
Und jetzt,
Chatke, gehe ich was essen,
weil ich habe überbrutalst Hunger.
Dem ich gestern schon weniger
gegessen habe, wegen Kotzkram
vorgestern.
muss ich jetzt mal ordentlich was futtern.
Pepo-Fat-Time, Leute.
Nicht Nudeln mit Lachs.
Testliche Suppe mit bisschen Toastbrot.
Bisschen Magenschon heute noch.
Wir hören uns.
Vielleicht heute Mittag.
Irgendwie habe ich Bock,
komm wieder nochmal zu schrieben.
Bis dann, macht's gut, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
See you.